Hey freaks sampling friends.
People offended by freak you to training.
Fuck's going on?
Don't say training.
You know how to say that anymore.
That's another new one.
They removed tranny tranny's ban.
Now even money saying that right now is very danger.
You removed to make a tranny also.
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
You rearrange your free range.
They're not supposed to say that anymore.
It's transgender.
You recycle.
Even if you love transgender people,
you're not allowed to say that.
Like even if you have nothing but love in your heart trainees out now it's
offensive.
I'll never be able to embrace it.
I accept it and I honor it,
but I fucking,
it does not me.
My head can't wrap around it.
You know what?
You had Ken rep around Greg Fitzsimmons and tell him,
God,
I need to tell your kid.
Don't.
Um,
if you ever have had to do anything,
uh,
legal involving,
like saying like setting up a corporation,
it's kind of a pain in the ass.
You've got to go to someone's office,
you got to pay some dude.
A lot of money.
Cost me a ton of money.
Yeah.
Well,
you can do it on legal zoom for 99 bucks.
They'll,
they'll talk you through it.
If you run into troubles,
they can connect you with the independent attorney if you need additional
guidance,
independent attorney.
So if you get to one of those situations where you're like,
you know what,
I think I might be fucked.
And you're looking at all you've created and you're like,
I don't think this is legal.
I don't think I know what I'm doing.
Like,
ah,
they'll hook you up.
And um,
legal zoom,
they want to emphasize that it's not a law firm.
They provide self help services at your specific direction.
But if you need things like,
if you need to write a will or need to do something along those lines,
you can do that online with legal zoom with legal zoom.com and it makes it much
easier than,
than going somewhere.
I mean,
this is where the world is coming.
Eventually you're gonna be able to do everything on your fucking computer.
I mean,
just like stamps.com this is the same kind of thing.
You're going to be able to do these things on your computer and legal.
zoom.com is an excellent example that the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used it and they take,
they saved a ton of money.
It's an excellent,
excellent service.
So coach
Greg Fitzsimmons and use a codename Rogan in the referral box for even more
savings.
All right,
my friends boom shall lock lock boom on at.com that's [inaudible] the sponsor.
If you go to Oh and and it and use a codename Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
That's Mike Dolce and he knows a lot about food,
but apparently he thinks he can eat wheat.
I've got to talk to them about that.
Kind of find out what if I'm wasting my time not eating wheat.
I'm old
free right now.
Greg Fitzsimmons,
I heard weed is the shit.
That's the new thing is it is the complete food source.
Really?
Yeah.
That's all.
That's all you need,
but that's that.
It's the best food source that is the the best in terms of the amount of
different nutrients and fiber.
It's a,
you go drink shots of wheat grass.
That's true.
Yeah.
That is true.
Is that the same though as we cross the same as wheat?
I don't think it does.
Doesn't it?
Liccardo Brown
shit that we have in Ohio that you chew on and when you're thinking about
things,
when you want to look [inaudible] right.
Um,
uh,
I don't know.
I'm trying gluten free for awhile,
seeing how it works so far,
so good.
But Mike [inaudible],
Scott,
uh,
ultimate grocery guide up there on,
on it.
You can learn more about that.
Mike Dolce is a,
a,
a guy that a lot of the MMA fighters use for uh,
their,
uh,
nutrition counseling.
He said it's a really smart guy when it comes to a diet.
Uh,
I saw,
I got to ask him about this wheat thing to find out what's good or bad about it.
But mostly what we sell on,
on it is things that can enhance human performance.
All stuff like strength and conditioning equipment,
supplements like hemp protein powder and things along those lines.
It's all just things that if you use them on a regular basis,
they can enhance human performance.
Whether it's medicine,
balls are weighted vests or Kettlebell Cardio,
DVDs,
all the stuff that we sell.
The idea is that it's going to enhance.
If you use it and you work out with it,
it'll enhance the way your body works.
If you take the supplements and it'll enhance the way your body functions.
I want big muscles.
You should get some.
I need some might need bigger mosques.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Commit.
Yeah,
because that's got all the time though.
Big Mouth.
I need to start backing it up and almost 50 like pocket.
Right?
I have to really knuckle up.
I'm not gonna calm down.
I'm tired of being the guy.
The sand kicked in his face.
O.
N.
N I t use the code name,
Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
Greg Fitzsimmons is in the fucking house.
My friends too at Brian [inaudible],
the Joe Rogan experience.
Let's try my day.
Joe Rogan block gas all day.
Sweet,
Sweet Greg Fitzsimmons.
You beautiful savage.
You always get to see my friend.
What a,
what a hang.
This is going to be baby kicking back.
Got some girl scout cookies and your special coffee,
what's it called?
It's called bulletproof coffee.
Oh Man.
That goes down smooth.
It's a Dave Asprey creation.
He,
he invented created and coffee with grass fed butter and MCT oils.
Medium triglyceride or oil.
It's,
it gives you a caffeine high and it's a lip balm.
Yeah.
It keeps it greasy.
Um,
the idea with it is that because it has the caffeine,
um,
blended in with the butter and the MCT oil,
that it's more of a slow release effect.
Right.
Takes your body awhile to digest it as opposed to like coffee just go right into
your bloodstream and you don't get the crash with this.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's much less than it could be a medicinal marijuana stuff is in the butter,
right?
Yes.
I do not know the,
I've never anything and they're cooked
anything.
I don't know the process,
but I know there's something involved cooking it to,
to activate the THC in an edible form.
I think though that you can get high with it if you just,
if you just eat it on its own.
Yeah,
but I think you have to eat an ass load of it.
I think it's no joke.
You have to like have salads.
Then maybe you can catch like a little bit of a buzz.
That's the new wheat man.
Yeah,
callous salads.
Did you hear about Sanjay Gupta?
CNN?
Fucking incredible.
I mean,
first of all,
props to CNN for Aaron.
This is guy for coming out with this.
This is incredibly controversial stance.
This guy,
Sanjay Gupta,
he went and over the last year he was working on a documentary called weed and
even he's,
he,
before he started this project,
he thought that marijuana was bad for you.
He thought marijuana was addictive.
He thought that marijuana was,
you know,
something that should be avoided.
And at the end of this project,
he's writing this story apologizing.
He says,
I apologize because I didn't look hard enough until now.
I didn't look far enough.
I didn't review papers from smaller labs and other countries doing some
remarkable,
remarkable research and I was too dismissive of the loud chorus of legitimate
patients whose symptoms improved on cannabis.
Instead I lumped him in with the high visibility mal liners.
Is that how you say that in a line or liners?
Just looking to get high.
I mistakenly believed that Drug Enforcement Agency listed marijuana as a
schedule one substance because of sound scientific proof.
Surely they must have quality reasoning as to why marijuana is in the category
of the most dangerous drugs that have no accepted medical use and use a high
potential for abuse.
So he wrote this long article,
I want to keep reading it and he also really limited.
He was wrong.
That's the really as a doctor to go on on Cameron say I was wrong.
I wonder though this,
this almost makes me wonder,
it's,
it's almost seems like some sort of a shift in policy because the reality of CNN
and Msnbc and Fox News,
these are giant companies.
They're huge companies.
They don't just say things,
they don't just say whatever the fuck they want to say.
None of that gets done.
They'd all go.
It has to go through a bunch of people and they have to decide what are we doing
this?
What are we doing?
Are we going to print this?
Is this going to Piss off Ted Turner?
Yeah.
Who's going to,
who's going to get upset by it?
This is going to cost anybody money.
Are we okay with this?
Should we move in this direction?
And then they printed a story like this because I just got to think that
something is big as CNN.
Like they could have said like maybe in the 80s if you tried to print the story,
they would have been like,
bitch,
get the fuck outta here.
Right.
We're not putting this on the air.
Well especially cause Nancy Reagan had just declared the war on drugs.
Yes,
exactly.
That just say no era.
That's when you and I started doing comedy.
It was like what a beautiful like kickstart everybody had to their act,
right.
There was always a drug war joke because it was so preposterous.
Kitty Dukakis drinking,
rubbing alcohol and war Andrea,
nobody remembers that story.
That was when Mike Dukakis was running for president and he is,
he had done it,
he had a couple of blunders,
that tank thing,
tank thing,
heard them got in a tank and put like a soldier's out front and let them take
pictures of them.
And everybody was like,
what the fuck?
Fuck us.
He was the wimpiest human being of it.
He was like worse than Ross.
Parral yeah,
they,
they've wanted to improve his image as a leader.
And so that was the end looked like,
um,
you look like a snail,
like this little wrinkly necks sticking out.
It was like Pale white face and he was one of this guys.
He is,
he's like,
um,
Ralph Nader in that he doesn't give a fuck that his suit isn't from Brooks
brothers.
Well Taylor's like asshole,
you're running for president.
You actually have to take the time to get a decent suit.
There's the picture.
Oh my God,
look at him.
Look at that shit.
Who told you that
did do that?
He's Kinda like a full helmet on and shit.
What does he do now?
I haven't heard anything about him in a long car ride.
Professor,
it's a good question.
Oh my God.
Can you imagine if doc that was your teacher in school while he's obviously a
brilliant man,
you know,
I think the,
the,
the idea of running for president,
it must be so fucking incredibly stressful.
I mean that you see a woman just completely lose it and start drinking,
rubbing alcohol.
I mean she just,
she's so,
she needs to get tanked up so bad and there's nothing in the house.
She's drinking aftershave.
Betty Ford.
Ah,
fuck man.
They were all drunks.
Imagine the pressure of the White House.
Just wrap your head around the pressure of making all the decisions of pressure
being the guy.
Everywhere you go,
this fucking six security everywhere around you.
Bulletproof cars and getting on jets and flying to other countries and you're
like the center of the representation of the conflict in the world.
Like fuck.
Not only that,
people were talking about like,
um,
those,
this fishermen that go out in the,
in Alaska and it's the most dangerous job.
How about this?
How about this statistic?
I looked this up,
I counted,
maybe I counted wrong,
but I think 10% of presidents have been killed in office or died in office.
So what other job would have a 10% chance of you dying in four years?
Not In the life of the job.
So you know,
you've got that hanging over your head.
The two best ones ever assassinated,
right?
Lincoln,
Kennedy.
I mean those are the heroes.
Those are the James Deans of of presidents.
Right.
If you look back at like who's the,
who's the bad motherfuckers a,
it was the guys that got killed.
Yeah,
those are the ones we miss.
Those are the ones that David Dads,
I was the one,
they were going to do it.
They were going to fix it.
Well,
and on the other side,
Reagan was that guy and they tried to kill him.
Well Reagan Wagan was a totally different animal.
You know,
it's interesting how Reagan like over time has become like something that's much
more acceptable to like absolutely.
Well time always whitewashes.
I mean,
Henry Kissinger,
that guy is,
he can't leave the country because he would be arrested as a war criminal in,
I forget how many countries it is,
but this motherfucker,
Kissinger ordered eee illegal bombings in Cambodia.
You know,
he,
I mean,
you're talking about genocide.
You if you are,
if you are flat out bombing carpet bombing a population that you're not at war
with,
that's a fucking war crime.
And now I just saw him on,
um,
curl a nut Corolla Kobe,
or last night they did a sketch with Kissinger and it's like,
no,
it's not funny.
It's not okay.
He's a fucked up human beings.
Wow.
I had no idea that he had done that.
Yeah.
I don't have any knowledge of 1970s politics.
I know.
Almost nothing.
I know a little bit about the,
uh,
the campaign that a hunter Thompson covered for fear and loathing on the
campaign trail,
which was great.
Yeah.
That's about my extent of my knowledge of 1970s politics.
Yes.
Have you ever looked into it though?
1970s period is,
uh,
eh.
I must've been molested
because I got nothing.
Well,
it's,
we were kids,
you know,
we're about the same age.
I'm 45 I'm already seven.
I'll be 46 soon.
Yeah.
Are you getting fucked in the ass by a neighbor?
Right.
You know,
we blocked it.
I was like [inaudible] maybe.
No,
I think just go fuck me in the ass.
So I just blocked out the 17th did you remember when you were really,
really young,
like going to dance clubs and trying to meet girls at the palace in revere?
Oh my,
it's not your place.
Well,
it was everybody's place.
If somebody wanted to go somewhere and try to meet a girl.
Yeah.
But the nice thing is so ridiculous.
I only went a couple times to those places with my friends and I always remember
being like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Like this kind of a crazy way to meet human beings.
Did you ever try country?
That was even worse.
Where you like go like,
wait,
you're supposed to square dance?
No.
Do do you remember the time we went to North Carolina with me at Charlie
Goodnight's?
We went next door to that bar.
That bar.
There's a bar,
right?
And they are all singing along to a song you never fucking heard in your life.
God,
the porch and health and there's singing this shit and they're going all around
the dancing,
that step dancing that they all do together that they did that.
They definitely did that too.
But this was another thing,
this is just another song that Brian and I had never fucking heard of him,
but apparently it's sold like 100 million,
you know,
albums in the south.
So we're in the south and this is like,
it comes on.
They're like,
whoa.
It was like,
I'm like,
we're in another country.
Like when you going to like
a place where their country fans,
that is a whole nother country.
That's the people who know who won Nascar.
Then you hear Dale did it again.
Did you hear he did it again.
And then there's fucking everybody that lives in that area.
I mean this is a different part of the world.
There's songs that they love that you have never fucking heard of and they'll be
like,
you ain't heard a clip driven.
No.
Clinton,
[inaudible] crip,
feminine,
so 14 million albums and you're like,
what?
He like Fuck is Clinton forever?
Like Pearl Jam sold 1 million and they are just as ridiculous as like Uber Golf
guys.
Cause you know how like Uber Golf guys to like wearing like black bake up.
You know they're like really like completely like posing and this bizarre thing
that they're doing.
What are you doing with a fucking cowboy hat?
Shithead with a turquoise belt buckle and slippery ass boots.
Those things are dumb.
What century you live in,
in?
What do you,
what are you doing?
He's like,
it's like people that maybe they love Halloween and they wanted to ground all
year.
You know,
I'm a cowboy.
No,
go on the porch.
What if the music doesn't even sell that well,
it's just that they're so dumb.
They keep on losing their cds that have to keep on buying them over and over.
Well look,
as far as outfits go,
cowboys,
a cool ass outfit.
That's one thing I have to admit.
Like if you dress not by your cowboy,
if you're a dude and you got the balls to rock cowboy boots and a Stetson going
ass jeans,
but even or not or not,
you know,
that is a ballsy move.
That's a ballsy look to commit to in the year 2013 I see.
Got then why not?
I know I'm not hating.
I just want to be clear about that.
I'm not hating.
If that's how you like to dress,
why not?
Why not?
Look at me.
I'm almost 50.
I dressed like a 15 year old.
Always have,
I dress like I dress like a junior coach.
I wear fucking varsity.
Coach has sweat fans.
Yeah.
You get to a certain point you like,
that's what's comfortable fucking most comfortable thing.
And then I think about people that you think about the possibilities in your
wardrobe.
They are limitless.
A woman could dress up as you know,
uh,
Queen Elizabeth every day as a guy.
Yeah.
These goth guys.
There you go.
Fuck it.
I'm painting my nails,
the whole thing.
I'm going to grow one.
I'm going to grow my pinky nail really long and he just fucking,
and it's like you could blow people away with that shit,
but I don't.
It's like the last thought in my head is to even make an impression with my
clothing.
I want it to be a zero.
But you should wear a whistle.
That would be funny.
It's why not?
That'd be hilarious.
Not just where a whistle.
Everything [inaudible] hilarious.
Not The coach man,
but now then you want to get somebody that tight channel.
That's great.
You're buying me a fucking whistle for my birth.
Right.
You imagine them dudes just started wearing whistles,
became the new cross,
like a cool whistle.
A whistle on.
Look.
It easily could be like you have a whistle and you're like,
Damn Bambi.
Like that could be the thing in clubs like,
oh you see how good he whistles.
Yeah.
And guys would be like a mating thing.
We would be like birds chirping at each other.
It's the rape,
strange whistles.
That lid on rape culture.
Whistle,
stop visit.
It's the meeting hall was short.
I was like,
she wants you to stop people in with the dance of noise.
If we can make cool noises,
like a whistle with our mouths.
I guess some people probably can.
There's dudes like Michael Wilson Woods,
low type dudes that can make strong water drop.
Isn't it funny though that that's such a,
it's such a valued skill.
All right,
that's pretty good.
You guys are fucking 12 years old.
That's what men get it.
That's what men do.
If you leave them alone,
leave them alone long enough.
They fucking sit in front of each other making stupid noises and then they buy
whistles.
Isn't it funny that like making cool sounds with your mouth is like a valued
thing?
Hell yeah.
I mean that's why like singers are so valued.
When someone does a really good singer,
you're like,
Whoa,
you know it makes you like step back.
Like Holy Shit.
Like Peter Frampton doing that.
We're
like,
that was the biggest fucking thing.
We thought that was the coolest.
And now you look back and you're like,
what was that wax paper and a calm.
That was when he had that thing that he put in his mouth.
Yeah.
You remember you put what was,
um,
what's the,
what are those things called?
What?
Talk about
talkbox.
Yeah,
yeah.
Whatever that thing is that rappers use all the time now.
The auto tuner.
Yeah.
Like little little Wayne eats through that thing.
He eats all his food through that thing here.
He uses it all the time,
but like Peter Frampton when he was doing it,
I guess it was like,
was it the eighties or seventies it must be the 79 I'm guessing that's what song
do you feel like I do?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
He was one of the first times anybody had ever done that and people were going
nuts.
Yeah.
They were going nuts.
Right.
I just remember like when I had a picture of a rock star,
just that line,
he had a woke up this morning with a wine glass in my hand.
Where the hell did I done?
That's all we want it.
We want it to become that guy who's in a penthouse suite with a wine glass in
his hand.
Yeah,
that's a great song.
Right.
Fucking song.
That was one song that defined that guy.
Yeah.
Like if you think of Peter Frampton,
Dan is the song you think of right away.
Cheap trick.
I want you to want me live at Buddha con.
What's crazy about Peter Frampton is it Peter Frampton was a guy who got famous
because of his live shows.
Is that right?
Yeah,
his live show was so fantastic.
He was such a showman that too.
Really appreciate his brilliance.
You had to see him rock a crowd.
Right.
And so when he does,
do you feel like I do in front of a crowd and he's got 20,000
people tuned in to him singing along with them.
Yeah.
It is some fucking magical shit.
And that's,
and he was one of the Florentine while he's dealing.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
He's a beautiful man.
And because he was like one of the first guys to put out like a live album like
that and that,
that was like one of his first big success,
right.
Was the live album.
That was really rare.
Right.
Usually people got a studio album and then maybe,
I think kiss was one of the first guys that said fuck it,
let's do a live one kiss a lot.
Cause they knew how to rock a show.
Like those shows were wild.
But Peter Frampton that do you feel like I do when he's got full control of that
crowd and they're singing along with them,
that is fucking magic.
That's a magic moment app.
Can you play a little bit of that?
Well play a little bit of that,
that Jim Morrison mystique where he was like,
you wanted to follow him into this world.
Yeah.
Predimed he was a bad mother fucker and he was uh,
who's a rock star in the mysterious days.
Right.
So completely different world.
Back then,
you know,
they could,
they didn't have Twitter where they said stupid shit and then had to delete it.
Like,
is this right?
These were wild dudes and they had no accountability.
It was like,
did you see almost famous?
Yes.
That was kind of like that I think in,
I think in the movie they're supposed to be following the almond brothers.
But,
but it was kind of a,
he said it was a mixture of a few different bands,
but it was from that exact time.
That's the limit.
Skinner,
Dara.
Right.
I mean that's,
those are,
those were wild motherfuckers,
man.
Right.
In my opinion,
the greatest guitar solo the world has ever known was Freebird.
Yes.
Freebird live.
Have you ever seen the one,
it's free bird live and they're jamming in front of a,
it's a football arena,
right?
So I don't know.
What is that 100,000 people and they are dirty white guys from Florida and
they're perfect.
They're perfect.
Every note is perfect.
Every fucking string is hit on the right time.
The fucking,
just the magical impact of that music.
Confident.
It's guys that have played teeth like the [inaudible] brothers.
This is,
these are the post post death.
You've got to go and get those underrated band by mainstream rock fans.
I Maynard.
Yeah.
Ban.
People have heard sweet home Alabama too many times.
That's the problem.
Yeah,
we've heard it so many times.
You're like,
oh,
get this off the air.
No,
no,
no.
You need to step back.
And with fresh eyes.
Listen to sweet home Alabama.
Cause that is a bucking beautiful,
simple man.
Yeah.
For Ballew to fall.
Beautiful.
Beautiful telling.
Your son had to grow up.
And one of my favorite things about skin is that they were ugly as fuck.
And almost every song was about getting away from women.
I got to juggle every song is they call me the breeze.
I got gotta go,
I see you.
I need to be free.
Right.
Gimme gimme three steps.
Yeah.
Get the fuck out of here.
Fucking song was like,
I gotta get Outta here.
See Ya.
[inaudible]
right.
You know,
and they even made songs about their friends trying to get them to settle down.
Well,
it was classic blues,
you know,
ugly.
Getting away from women.
Yep.
You know,
being at the crossroads and a lot of it is about the devil.
There's just so many knuckleheads that love scattered.
Yeah.
That's the problem.
The problem is it,
it,
you know,
they died young.
Okay.
And you,
you have an issue when you have so many knuckleheads,
like a band,
you can get diluted.
Oh,
that's for knuckleheads.
No,
no,
the grateful dead.
I actually liked the grateful dead.
Grateful dead.
Don't do it for me.
They're fans are a,
they,
they their buzz killed my cousin and followed them around for like years.
Like was a deadhead.
Yeah.
She uh,
she,
her and her boyfriend would like sell food.
I'm just going to say they always have like a little business take care of some
gallon.
Yeah.
And just go from show to show.
And they were just,
I guess they were just enjoying that community.
It must be very strange to be like an outlaw like that.
Just to a rebel from society going from concert to concert with the little tiny
mini ecosystem of selling scrambled eggs out of the back of your car,
meeting with all these people and I'll fucking tripping together and always
trying to get a ticket.
They would have signs up.
I need a miracle.
Oh Wow.
That was the sign that you were a real dad had not just some dude,
I need a miracle.
And then the,
and then they'd get them and you know,
it was,
it was just like a living from Vegan Tofu.
Patty.
Just making enough to get that fucking ticket.
It's so weird,
but I get it.
I get it.
I totally get it.
You know what I get?
I get,
there's a lot of people doing it and it looks like fun.
I get that.
It's like,
well this is like an ecosystem.
This is like a little community that you can link up to.
And these guys actually like it.
Like,
you know,
it's like everybody's happy and they're all meet together and at the,
they perform these four fucking hours shows and everyone's on acid dancing.
I mean,
I,
I'm telling you,
Springsteen is a,
is a fucking experience live.
I heard you two is but a grateful dead concert.
I mean,
your,
first of all,
you tripping.
Every single person is dancing,
not bouncing back and forth.
Fucking are doing the backstroke and looking at the sky like that is really
intense to be surrounded by that for four hours.
So is that what it's all about?
Yeah.
It's letting go into this energy.
Is it,
is it a show that requires drugs?
Yes.
Does.
Yeah.
And is it a show that you don't understand until you do it with drugs and then
you understand it 100% like you ever the worst feeling in the world.
Young words give or go to a concert like pipe.
My wife made me go to fucking Dave Matthews band.
Oh God,
right son.
That's the ugly one.
And the word wife made me go to is always bad.
But then when you say,
I shouldn't say the only thing worse than Dave Matthews is John Meyer.
Oh,
John Meyer.
And she was just like John Mayer Meyer and she,
and she was just like just enthralled by him.
[inaudible] Huh?
I could do John Mayer will know.
I can do to,
no,
I think he's great.
I think he's very talented.
But if your wife is really into going,
oh,
I know what I'm saying.
Like she dragged you there and just stares at him,
right?
And you're like,
I made for this ticket.
You paid to have your wife close.
Arise later and think about him.
Boop.
Ley,
you notice she's not clapping because one of her hands slipped down or James
knuckle deep.
Oh,
Dave Matthews.
He's so sad today.
She's clapping
being with one hand.
Yeah.
It's just like,
it sounds like something stabbing of seal.
Just what
it sounds like.
One of those martial arts movies where they rip the guy's heart out.
[inaudible]
she's just fist of herself.
She's all the way to right elbow.
Just written her teeth and Brown it in there.
Get the wedding ring off.
She's just fucking strafing the,
you can see her rib cage
ban is a Fisk goes up there,
John Meyer.
I fucking love you.
Okay,
let's go here.
Then you realize it's in her asshole.
You thought it was bad.
It's all fucking shit up to her elbow.
What is this the fuck are you doing?
I thought we were going to see a concert.
She starts licking your arm.
Oh,
John Mayer.
John.
Uh,
you make me eat my shit.
Lo.
Meanwhile,
that's not the craziest person that ever lived.
Nope.
That's not even close.
Don't even call close.
If you work in an insane asylum,
that's all they do is clean shit up off the walls.
It's all about feces in the mental institutions.
Yeah.
What does that they say that has something to do as a territorial proud.
Oh,
I didn't hear that.
I've heard a lot of,
there's a lot of connections between like feces,
abuse and sexual abuse.
Right.
Read that though.
Online.
Obviously I'm not a doctor.
I know when I think about the seventies and I take a shit,
I cry when you think about the 70s and you'd take your shit.
Yeah.
Cause I was molested in the 70s and then when you're taking a shit,
no,
we're just making that joke before.
Remember
good.
But we were been met.
He thought that would be edited out.
I thought we were figuring out a way to move past that.
Do you guys know a band named one direction?
Oh No.
Yes.
It's a,
it's a kid's band.
Like if Tiger beat had had a cover story.
Oh look at these cute little bastards.
Yeah.
But I guess they're staying at the hotel across the street from the comedy
store.
There's all these little kids that are just hanging out there late at night,
just like in groups like,
like,
like an apple products about to get released at midnight type shit.
Oh,
and they're just mobbed everywhere.
Like how fucked up is that is these guys,
you know,
they're trying to make them look like they're 17 but they're probably 25 right
after days or whatever.
Find out even if they're 21 the fans 11 to
1314 and they want to fuck you or they don't know what they want.
They want to let you do what you want with them.
So I was wondering if these guys are like looking for that one older sister who
is into it log or that you should be and she's like 1718 and you want to pluck
her out because otherwise it's a nightmare.
All these people are screaming for you and you can't go near them.
Do you think the girls actually want them to do what they want to them?
I think they have no idea what the fuck they want.
They want to hug them or something.
You know,
you're talking about an 11 year old.
I don't think.
I don't,
you know,
I think they don't even realize what a guy liking you means,
you know?
But some of them are dressed like dirty whores.
They're like 13,
but they,
you know,
maybe 13.
Yeah.
Then you start kind of figuring it out.
What is it,
11 how many kids at 11 no.
What's going on?
What if your wife though?
Like it was the opposite.
What if your wife was in love with like Justin Bieber?
Like,
like just a huge Bieber fan.
There was parents that were hanging out with these kids and they were like,
all like with the t shirts,
I'm like,
like freaking out off.
It was just as creepy.
Hmm.
Makes Sense.
I mean,
he's a,
he's a handsome ambassador that Justin Bieber,
Justin Bieber is cute,
just adorable.
And he never breaks character.
He's always that fucking positive guy,
you know?
But now you hear he's starting to fuck up.
He was,
uh,
he,
he pissed in a janitor's bucket behind it and a nightclub.
I think the pressure that dude must be under must be staggering.
And it's staggering.
He was,
what,
12 six yeah.
So we never had a chance to develop an in any normal way.
Yeah.
To for him,
the,
the struggle is going to be so strange.
And you know who gave me some insight into that is a Ricky Schroder.
Ricky Schroder was famous when he was like six.
Yeah.
Isn't like that movie the Champ,
I think he was like six,
six or seven or something like that.
Get nominated for an Oscar.
Dude,
he fucking deserved it.
He was amazing in that,
but he,
the way he describes it,
when he did the podcast,
he talked about,
he's like,
that's my world.
I've never known another world man.
I've never known a time where I wasn't famous.
So it's normal to me.
Yeah.
And I go,
oh,
all right.
I'm like,
what is an interesting way to grow?
Is Justin Bieber about to kick some ass?
Is that what's going on?
What is he going?
Who is he going after?
A reporter.
Yeah.
Well that seems like it could have been handled a little better,
but there's a lot of big actors to start as child actors.
You know,
like Tom Cruise and,
oh,
what's his name?
Uh,
Leonardo Dicaprio.
You know,
he was probably 11 when he started.
Yeah.
And I think in a way,
maybe you can't stay at the level that a Tom cruise does unless you just were
indoctrinated into it early and it's all,
you know,
maybe.
I mean there's some that seem to have gotten through it.
Like,
I don't know,
I've never had a conversation with Jodie Foster,
but she strikes me as someone who got through it like fairly unscaved.
She's a lesbian.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
Like
that made it easier?
It's a better transition.
No,
I,
I think that being a lesbian makes you from the lesbians I've known and I've
known some really well.
I worked for,
Alan did generous for two years and I think that it makes you an outlier.
You're born into being an outlier.
You're already thinking about things knowing you,
you don't need people's approval cause you're not going to get it categorically.
So you stopped seeking it.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
You know,
because one of the things that I always admire about,
uh,
talking to a fun lesbians is how they're very much like,
guys don't make jokes and you don't give a fuck.
Like Melissa Etheridge.
She's like a dude.
Yeah.
I mean,
and I say that in the nicest way possible.
The,
the broadest sense of the compliment.
She was,
uh,
she was talking about divorce and alimony and stuff like that,
and she goes,
hey,
you know,
look,
the bottom line is women are fucking crazy.
She's just talking about getting divorced and she's talking like a dude.
You know what I mean?
And I don't mean all women are crazy.
Some of them are great,
don't,
don't put,
the lesbians are less crazy.
But once beings are more like dudes,
right?
Like there's something anybody,
he doesn't believe that that is a natural part of the,
the,
you know,
the broad spectrum of,
of sexual attraction is a natural part of life.
It's never met like a badass lesbian,
you know,
you never met like a Melissa Etheridge.
If you met,
met a Melissa Etheridge,
you'd be like,
Oh yeah,
oh yeah,
that's,
that's a lesbian [inaudible] we have so many
same sex parents and my,
in my kids' school,
it's crazy.
They have absolutely no concept that to gay people shouldn't be together any
more than like when they heard about that,
they,
that the supreme court overruled that same sex marriage act.
They were like clapping in the back of the car.
Wow.
They're just like,
would,
why would to like Jeremy's parents,
you know,
uh,
Evans mothers,
like it's just fucking normal.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
you know,
people have this idea somehow or another that there's,
there's different teams that there's a conservative team against the liberal
team.
Really what you should look at this,
the simplest way,
simplest ways.
Does it hurt you?
And if it doesn't support it,
does it,
does these people enjoy it?
Well,
there's some important,
like the,
the idea that you would restrict people's behavior that they enjoy because for
some reason it's distasteful to you,
that's just being an asshole.
That's all that is.
That he's ain't nothing worse.
It falls under that category.
Abortion gets tricky because you're dealing with human life and it's also tricky
because it's one of those clear pattern decision things like if you're a right
wing person,
you are pro life.
If you're left wing person you are pro choice.
It's almost like cut and dry like you have to adopt these opinions to be one
side or the other.
I think I have no business to tell anybody what they can and can't do with their
body.
I have no business,
I'm not a doctor.
I don't know when life begins but it you look at like a of couple cells together
and then you look at a forming fetus.
They become very different things as it becomes larger and older.
So then it starts to be when it's,
when does it become life and I think that's a real question and I don't think
it's a left wing question or rightwing question
to question.
It gets people and asking in a written way.
Exactly.
It's an honesty question and it's a question that we avoid in this discussion.
It's,
you're either,
if you're left wing person,
you are a pro choice and you want women to be able to do this safely and you
want it to be,
uh,
where they don't have to worry about being harassed in the parking lot.
And if you're a right wing person,
oftentimes the views,
the polar opposite that you're taking a human life,
it's against the Bible.
If you're,
you know,
a Christian,
especially he,
there's a lot of people that believe this is a terrible,
terrible thing.
So terrible that there's the extremists when you get on their spectrum,
the extremists that shoot the fucking abortion doctor,
which is totally logical to me and I understand it.
If I believe,
if I believe that absolutely that human lives are being taken,
it will be the same to me as if I knew that there was a guy that was going to
work every day and they were killing people.
I would,
I would kill that person.
I would be within my moral authority,
not by the United States law,
but I feel the same way.
If somebody hurt someone in my family,
rape or murder,
I would get a gun and I would go find that her,
I would arrange to have them killed.
And I would feel like that wasn't wrong of me to do that if I was absolutely
sure it was,
it was them.
Right.
But in terms of when a life begins,
you remember Jonathan Katz is joke,
he goes,
I believe life begins after the Second Cup of coffee.
Jonathan Katz is awesome.
But yeah,
it's a real question.
And if you bring it up like that,
I had a discussion with this guy that I really kind of respected,
I don't want to say his name,
but I was uh,
who was the most preposterous discussion on the idea that it's just a seed and
that,
uh,
you know,
having an abortion is just to seed.
I'm like,
it's not just a seed,
it's a growing thing.
Like if you leave it alone,
it's going to be a person.
We both know that like,
we can't play games with this.
And then you start accusing me of being right wing like immediately.
And I was like,
okay,
I'm not,
I'm not right wing at all,
but you're saying you're equating it to a seed.
It's not a seed like a fetus.
Something growing inside of your body will be a human.
A seed does not necessarily become a tree.
Okay.
You have to fucking plant it.
You got to water it.
Then it becomes a sapling and then it's on its way and if it gets the moisture
then it becomes,
it becomes a tree,
but a seed can just sit around for a long time.
Once you have a baby that started to grow,
then the ethical process begins.
The ethical question process.
When is it a person?
Is it a person a day
in when it's two sales or three sales or a hundred sales,
whatever the fuck it is.
Is it really?
Are you sure?
Like if I just pulled that out of there real quick,
aren't we good?
Yeah.
The discussion seems to me off.
It's off point because it really is like very logically it is the second it
becomes two cells and anything in between that and birth is life.
Yeah.
Then the question really is about when is it less of a bad thing?
Is it sooner?
You know,
cause to me it feels like to say,
well once it has eyes or to say once it starts to delineate limbs,
then you start to go like,
well now you're splitting hairs.
I mean either you are stopping,
uh,
you know,
an entity from fully forming or you're not.
And it doesn't matter how far down the line is.
And this isn't to say I'm against abortion,
but like I do a joke about it now where I say,
you know,
women are like,
first I asked the women who,
how many women are pro choice?
They all clap.
How many of you have had abortions?
Nobody clapped.
I go,
there's the problem with your fucking cause.
How are you going to really fight for a cause?
You won't admit that you actually do.
I said,
you should be proud of it.
This should be,
you should see like,
uh,
you should see like a those silhouettes of the family members in the back of
your minivan with just an x three one of them and says not a good time.
And it just,
to me it feels like I,
now that might come off as anti abortion,
but it's not.
It's anti put your head in the sand.
It's like own it.
If you're gonna fucking do it,
own it.
The same way that I would own masturbation.
If you tried to make it illegal,
I'd be like,
fuck you.
I may be ashamed of this,
but I'm fighting for my right to have.
I can see the cover of the article you're writing on Joseph Bell right now.
Emmy Award winning writer
connects masturbation with them.
Abortion.
Look,
we're all ashamed,
ladies.
They were both cleaning up afterwards.
Oh God,
how dare you.
This is where women who are like really militant,
we'll get furious.
Like,
you know,
you can never fucking have a conversation about it because the option isn't
available to you.
Okay?
You're not going to have a fucking body growing inside of your body and you're
not going to be the person who gives birth.
And my answer would be,
I've never dropped seat in a chick with that protection dummy.
Oh,
how'd you get pregnant?
Dare you?
How dare you yell at someone so vulnerable in
the middle of a crisis.
You exploding on a stranger.
I know I have to meet it with love.
I have to be gentle of love.
It's hard to do,
but sometimes we need to do to fix the world.
Sweet.
Well you can't,
you can ever say,
why didn't you just about the past and having sound good?
Why didn't you just get your shit together?
Oops.
Just
call me because I was fucking suicidal.
I don't want to talk to anybody.
Well,
not allowed to say it's dark
when you say,
uh,
if you say suicidal around people,
that's the best way to get the party stopped.
Everyone's having a good time.
Well,
ever since I've been suicidal cricket,
oh no,
no,
no.
Nobody wants to be around somebody who wants to end life on their own terms for
some reason.
That's very disturbing to us.
Yeah,
most likely.
Because if you're,
if you're looking to kill yourself,
what do you give a shit?
If I die too?
I don't know.
Not committed suicide.
Bomb Yourself.
Right.
Did you,
did you watch that show?
Um,
uh,
fuck the Patriot show.
Uh,
ha.
Steelers won on no Herron teacher.
The one,
the fucking the homeland.
I've seen every episode.
Fascinating fucking show.
Fuck.
Yeah.
And I don't want to spoiler alert,
but the,
those suicide vest scene.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's an Emmy Award winning performance right there and shit.
I don't want to say anything more than that.
You're about to watch one of the best actors out there.
Holy Shit.
What a scene.
I mean,
they,
they the cast and that's your Mandy Patinkin.
I'd always heard his name,
but I thought he was like some theater.
Huh?
He's not,
he's a fucking,
well,
he's that too.
I know,
but that made me think that he was just like,
uh,
you know,
for lack of a better word,
like a,
you know,
a homosexual.
Oh,
Hey Zov which isn't bad.
I just met,
I dismissed him as like a cabaret singer.
Oh.
And I didn't realize he was like a brilliant fucking actor.
Yeah.
Mandy Patinkin beast man.
He's a beast.
He was also in the princess bride.
He was legal Montoya.
Right,
right on my father prepare to die.
He was a bad mother fucker.
Mandy Potemkin has been a bad mother fucker for a long time.
He's a brilliant actor and he plays that character.
Just,
it's just a work of art.
It is a work of art.
I mean the,
the subtlety in his delivery side,
the,
the real moments when he actually gets upset be that tangible feeling that you
have when this really measured guy has to cut loose and get crazy.
Right.
Fuck what a show.
And you know,
you talk about characters being layered,
it's like there's so many different things going on with him between his
troubled marriage,
his relationship with Claire Dane,
which he knows is wrong and yet he believes in her and he's a company man.
In the end,
it's,
there's so many different things going on with him and he plays all of them at
the same time.
Yeah,
it's so,
it's so hard to believe that.
I mean,
and again,
spoiler,
I'm not going to say,
but it's so hard to believe the plot lines they've pulled off.
Like the idea that they put forth that,
that they're actually playing that out and then I'm not running away from the TV
going get the fuck out of here.
Like they haven't had me go get the fuck Outta here once.
Well I th I felt 24 was like that 24 you had to suspend your disbelief a little
bit more because it was a little bit more of action.
It was physical action more.
Right.
But it was the same kind of shit that
you would really go like and I,
that's why I love that genre.
I love Bourne supremacy.
I like it when you got to go like,
yeah,
they're not riding a motorcycle truss and roof,
but fuck man,
this,
this is fun to watch.
Yeah.
I mean,
even if it's preposterous,
the Bourne identity one,
what's the latest one?
The latest one is the,
the not,
it's the one that's not Matt Damon.
It's the other guy.
Oh,
I didn't see the new guy.
I can see Jeremy Renner.
Jeremy Renner.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah.
Um,
and he's like jumping off the top of buildings and landing on people's necks,
twist to them on the way down.
I mean,
it's the most ridiculous shit of all time.
He's like this.
These are like the greatest Olympic athletes the world has ever known.
This dude got do.
Yes.
The thing he can say like in the movie for kind of stuff,
anything,
everything.
He does,
whatever he flashed through the Lens.
I mean,
it's preposterous.
Like the way he can more than Matt Damon.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's on,
he's the hyper level.
They kicked it up.
So it's more like bond.
Yeah,
no,
no.
He's more like a superhero.
Like what he can do with his body is ridiculous.
He literally jump off buildings and land on people's heads,
catch himself and buildings on the way down.
Trop on their head and snap them and fucking flip off.
Flip over a speeding Ferrari that's coming at them under this arm.
Grab that guy,
turn it towards up.
Don't Joe jumped chill.
Everybody in front of him.
Flip over him when the car's coming at him.
I mean it's just,
I always like,
you know,
have your leg broken and in the next scene chase somebody down.
That's always my favorite.
I'm always keeping track of how injured because at at my age,
like I get injured just getting up,
taking a shit,
I can get injured and I'm watching this guy,
oh,
you know,
finger must be broken from that.
I got gouged out from that.
And he's still at the top of his game in the last scene.
Yeah.
They,
they heal well no,
those shows,
they always get that streak of blood that comes off the eyebrow.
And it was a big one.
You know what the key is?
Is the,
the acting.
I mean,
Matt Damon is just a guy,
he can do comedy,
drama,
Romance.
He's fucking unbelievable.
He's a beast.
And so you put him into a role like that and he raises the stakes if you
believing in it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
he was so good that he played Liberace's lover.
And you believed that God,
you know?
Yeah.
You meet Matt Damon is a bad motherfucker.
Lisia so is that what it's called?
The new futuristic movie?
Elysium Elise.
Elisa may see him.
At least him.
That looks awesome.
Yeah.
I don't know what that is.
I don't know if it's good,
but at least one of those few actors where you know,
some of these guys get paid 20,
$25 million a picture and you think that's not worth it.
There's very few people that I will go see,
like fucking don't need to read a review with the movie.
Don't care who the director is.
Matt Damon's in it.
I will go say it.
Yeah.
He always makes a good choice.
Right.
The movies are always there.
So,
oh,
something really good about the movie.
Yeah.
What was the one movie where he played a complete total liar?
Oh,
about,
he was,
uh,
he was flying around a lot.
Right.
The curious of what the fuck was that?
Oh God damn it.
Now I've got to go to is yeah,
that I am DB,
which I never liked to do.
That
was bad.
What's your I MTB man.
Really not impressed hoes.
That's what people like to say.
It's like a,
yeah,
that's a Hollywood douche thing.
I had been to your imdv bro.
Not only that,
I am,
DB has a star ranking.
Here is the most grit task Hollywood sign.
You can pay extra,
you pay an extra 10 bucks a month for IMD be pro and you can,
I can look up Joe Rogan and it will you,
you will be numbered from one to like 10 million in Hollywood based on the
amount of searches for your name.
Um,
you know,
time spent on your website.
It's all factored in and you get a ride.
Like usually,
you know,
like,
uh,
Matt Damon might be number three and I might be like number 46,000 or something.
So I know this 46,000 people higher up in the food chain in Hollywood than I am.
And you can look up any,
you have a meeting with somebody,
you can look up what their fucking ranking is in Hollywood.
That's so ridiculous.
That's just something that people would get caught up in and then it would wind
up becoming really gross.
Right.
You'd just get caught up in it and lose your fucking marbles.
Hire a marketing team to search you.
So you go up in the,
yeah,
ranking.
I need to get my public internet profile higher in the rankings.
It's very important.
I can't find the name of this fucking movie.
What's so crazy is like with
with Twitter,
there's times where I go through Tweets,
I,
I stumble on something that makes me laugh and I'll write out like five,
six,
seven tweets in 20 minutes and then I won't tweet for like five days.
And then I'll see like the number of people that follows you will jump when you
write tweets and then it doesn't at all.
When you don't see,
you realize like you really,
it's great that people are,
they really are reading that shit.
Oh yeah man.
If you are,
if you're interesting to follow,
like people send you interesting things as well.
Look,
one of the beautiful things about Twitter is that it's like an exchange.
Yeah.
Like I retweet a lot of shit and I retweet things that people send me that that
are interesting.
Like someone will send me some crazy story about some new scientific discovery
and then I'll immediately retweet that.
And so it encourages people to do that because they like being retweeted cause
they get more followers that way.
And if you have cool shit on your tweet,
your Twitter page,
like people who have,
you know,
no show business connections at all,
they just have developed a following,
have like significant numbers of Twitter followers just based on their own
input.
Denny's.
Yeah.
Someone finds out about it or you tweet something to someone famous and they
retweet it.
Someone finds out about it.
And then before you know it you have like this little community that you've
developed.
Well writer is on TV are getting jobs from,
from Twitter feeds more than SPEC script.
That's amazing.
You hear about it all the time.
This dude,
you know,
he went to uh,
um,
you know,
Colorado State University and he just used to tweet a lot and then he,
he,
he just gets fucking,
they solicit him.
You know,
you guys,
I'll have a 200,000 followers and they'll say,
do you want to write on a how I met your mother?
And the guy does it and then he kills himself.
That's amazing.
You imagine writing on how I met your mother,
one of those shows sitting in a room with 12 other people fighting to get one
line into a horrible script.
But folks don't know that.
Everyone's like,
yeah,
must be really fucking hard working on TV must be terrible.
Excuse me while I go to the coal mine.
Right?
That's obviously worse,
right?
But doesn't take away from the fact that being on a show that sucks is torture.
Well,
and I only say that because as Comedians we get to say whatever the fuck we
want,
we can,
uh,
we can get immediate feedback.
Nobody's giving us notes or criticism.
And then you take that and you go into,
uh,
you have an office and then some pa will come by and go,
okay,
everybody in the writer's room and you have to stand up and walk in and sit down
and stay in there for the four hours until they go,
okay,
you guys can have lunch.
It's just your whole life turns upside down.
Yeah.
And again,
that this isn't a complaint about it.
I'm just saying compared to stand up.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Stand up is the greatest job the world has ever known.
An hour a night.
Yeah.
And just writing during the day.
And usually it's fun.
Even the,
even the stuff you're like,
God,
I gotta right.
When you start writing and it clicks,
that's a fun feeling.
Right?
It's really fun.
And the,
and the excitement of then knowing like you're driving to the club and you got
like three
is a new shit.
Yeah.
You got like a little bomb that you know you can drop.
That's a great feeling.
It's so fun and you're,
it's also,
people love that feeling.
I loved that feeling of laughing at someone.
Like I'm still a huge fan of standup.
Like one of my favorite things to do is to go watch standup.
This is one of the reasons why it was really fun.
Those dates that you and I did together.
I got to watch you and laugh and I hadn't seen a lot of your stuff in a while.
It was really fun.
Yeah.
Stand up is just a,
it's a beautiful exchange.
I was just the Montreal comedy festival I saw cause all these dudes that I'd
heard about and hadn't seen for whatever cause you know we're on the road at the
same time.
But you know Kyle Kinane.
Yeah,
I don't know him.
I know who he,
I guess the same thing.
I hadn't seen him and he was fucking great.
Like uh,
like a Stan hope to kind of guy just,
you know,
a boozer who talks really honestly about the darkness of his life and his butt
but has the chops of a real stand.
Yeah,
I saw him do,
I've seen him do one set and it was at the Improv and it was very fun.
Yeah.
But it was a long time ago.
It was several years ago.
It's hard for him to remember his Twitter Avatar is,
it's my cat.
It's your cat would really,
oh,
that's funny.
You mean the photo,
the drawings are you of him holding techie?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Well it's tough to beat a cute cat.
And then I went and we did,
we,
I did a appealing to look at,
you know,
they have that Gallo where you got to go and perform for like 3000 people and if
they show it around the world.
Oh yeah.
So I paid that.
And a Dane Cook was like,
they have a host for
it,
you know,
a celebrity host.
And Dane Cook was the host when I was doing the,
you know,
and usually you draw old people cause it's like a seven o'clock show in
Montreal,
a second old Jewish town.
And I have fucking choked on my own semen in front of these crowds.
And this time it was like Dane's fans and they were young and fucking excite.
He went out and killed first and it was all Boston guys was Bobby Kelly,
me,
Gary Gulman,
Dane,
um,
uh oh.
And Alonzo Boden and Harland Williams.
Everybody had a great time.
It was such a fucking relief.
Oh that's cool.
Yeah.
I think that whole old people thing or that's from a different era.
I've been hearing that the,
the,
the comedy festivals have um,
skewed younger and younger these days.
No,
just this one particular shot of the gala.
TV taping?
No,
no,
I'm saying they do like seven Gal during the week and each night they do one.
So the one I was on had a much younger crowd than the other ones.
Oh.
So they did have ones with a lot of older folks cause it's a tape TV show.
So they buy the tickets way in advance.
Oh see cause I always felt like the people that had been going to the comedy
festival,
we're sort of,
there was a lot of like,
um,
when we started going,
I,
the first time I went,
I think it was 93 and there was still that push to be TV clean.
Right.
And they were also,
like the gala was only TV clean so I never got to work at.
So I,
but from what I would think now is that you see all these clips from the thing
and then it's on the internet and then stand up.
Comedy becomes more and more popular,
which I think stand up comedy is probably at,
at one of its more popular times.
If you stop and think about like how many really good comedians there are right
now,
it's unbelievable.
That's,
it blew me away
trail.
I was like,
this is a 100 comics here and they're all fucking good.
Yeah.
And I would think that it would be a lot of young people that would show up now
to these things.
I think the other ones,
like I did moon tower,
which is in Austin,
Texas back in like April or May and that was very young.
And then you've got south by South West.
I mean Coachella does a comedy stage.
Bumbershoot in Seattle.
Chicago has a big one.
Um,
San Francisco has a sketch fest.
did you know there's a million of them.
It's hilarious that some of them don't pay the artists they did.
They'd literally a mantra I'll pays.
Yeah,
Montreal pays.
Yeah.
They've always paid.
They paid back in 1993 when I first started doing it.
Right.
But like south by southwest doesn't give you anything
now.
And the only reason I did Moontower is I was headlining cap city in Austin that
week.
So I was making my headline or money and I was part of the festival at the same
time.
Did you do shows before or after your shows at Cap City?
I know I would do,
you know,
eight o'clock show Thursday to Friday to Saturday,
but then beef.
But then after my shows I would go do like midnight shows.
But then also the people at the festival with the,
you know,
the,
um,
customers,
they,
Dave would have a laminate and they'd go see my show maybe,
and then they see posts sane show after that.
It was part of the whole thing.
Wow,
that's awesome man.
Sounds like a good time.
You should do it because they do some theater shows and it is a fucking cool
vibe.
It likes Stan Hope.
Was there hung out with standard?
No,
I'm thinking Tom Rhodes was there like guys,
I never fucking see and,
and the crowds are,
I mean,
you work Austin though.
The greatest crowds.
I was just there.
I guess those are like five or six months ago he got to do Moontower.
I'll do it if I can.
I don't know.
I'm so fucking busy these days.
Yeah.
But this one is,
this is a rejuvenative week where yous,
you chill,
you feel,
you walk away,
you've seen some good new comedy,
reconnected with some friends,
Dunston.
So like a a comedian meeting hub,
right?
Yeah.
That's what Montreal always felt like.
That bar,
that co to the delta,
is that what it's called?
Right?
Yeah.
That bar.
That's right.
Yeah.
That bar is always been,
you know,
it can be landmines though,
because you never know where you're gonna run into that one shitty club on or
who's going to be in your face or gay comedian who's drunk and ruthlessly
aggressively pursuing you.
He's the only time I've ever done my rarer.
No,
Tom can kiss me anytime you want.
I don't let them penetrate,
but she wants a kiss me and jerk off.
I love him.
Um,
I'm playing pool with dom on Sunday.
Looking forward to it.
I love seeing him.
Somebody I always see at the clubs too.
Like I'll be at the Improv at one in the morning.
You walk.
Yeah.
Dom's legit to the,
to the end.
He's a legit standup comedian.
Always working.
Always has a notebook with them.
I always got new shit,
you know,
he's just awesome
and he's got that energy before he goes on.
Just the way good comics did.
Still not nervous,
but yes.
Asked up,
hyper focused.
He loves it and he's always loved it.
We've been friends.
Dom and I have been friends since [inaudible] 93 I met him in [inaudible] 93
when I did a,
the festival in Montreal and then we became friends after we ran into each other
at Amsterdam billiards.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Cause I had just done that show with them.
But that was the first time I'd ever met him.
And he's the host of it.
It was a showtime thing.
And then when we went,
uh,
to play at Amsterdam,
I found out he could play pool angel like renders club.
Yeah.
The,
and the old one,
remember the old one that was on the upper west side?
That one was awesome.
He would,
so I've been friends with dom since,
uh,
I guess it was like 93.
He's always been that way.
It's always been like a real comic.
And he's like the Don Gavin of La.
He will talk to any young comic,
be funny with them,
bust their balls and uh,
treats you with,
he says nice things to you.
You don't get enough of that.
He's compliment you if you do a new bit that he likes.
He's a beautiful person.
Yeah.
I love dot Merera with,
with all my heart.
He's beautiful.
I love being around him.
He's fucking hilarious.
He goes,
sweet,
warm guy.
Some say the other night,
he goes,
ah,
I'm at the age where if I died of natural causes,
people go,
hmm.
And the other one he said,
he said,
I wish I was gay.
Just so I could come out of the closet.
That's how little I give a fuck.
I'm bored.
I need something fun to do with Edo.
He really does not care what people think about him.
And he's happy with who he is.
He's not struggling with that.
So,
but yet,
plus he's on Xanax,
so he's like,
whatever.
I don't give a fuck why.
I knew he quit drinking for a little while.
I don't know if you've asked it.
Well,
he got a little out of the,
he was a little out of control slightly,
but he not nothing.
He's smart enough to like pull back on his own and then he resumed casual
drinking.
All right.
But,
uh,
I think,
look,
it's easy.
You're a single guy.
You're in clubs every night and he's in clubs almost every night.
It's easy to start drinking a lot.
It's fun.
Fun.
Yeah,
it's fun.
You're having a good time.
Then you have a couple of shots.
Now you're having a great time.
Woo.
But you know that the crushing effect that has on your body over and over and
over again,
it's right.
Bad for him.
All right.
I Miss Drinking,
man.
Fuck.
I just had my family stay with me for a week.
My sister,
her husband who drinks and uh,
my niece and nephew and my mother all stay into my,
my house with my wife for two,
nine of us.
Oh cry.
But you know what?
And I miss drinking because they would all drank a lot at night.
They'd go through bottles and bottles of wine and my uh,
brother-in-law go through a couple of six pack of Budweiser and uh,
and so you start to really feel it.
Like even my wife who doesn't drink a lot was drinking everyday.
So I'm all alone.
I'm drinking non alcoholic beer is,
and I'm playing fucking playstation when my kids,
cause I can't relate to people,
get people get fucking dumb and boring when they drink.
I'm sorry,
it's nice at first,
but if you're the sober one,
everybody gets emphatic about their point of view and an overly zealous about
simple thoughts.
And uh,
you just start to feel yourself squeezed out.
They start to feel like people are looking at you like you're the uptight guy
and you can't have a good time.
And so I want to go to counterpoint on what you just said.
Unless,
unless everyone drinks the Kool aid,
it's not fun.
Well,
it depends on who you're drinking with.
If you drink it with idiots,
you're going to have that product.
And about my family.
I'm talking about your phone.
I'm calling them idiots.
I'm calling mine too.
My wife,
everyone's an idiot.
I'm an idiot.
You're an idiot as well.
It's all in the level of idiot,
right?
And with a certain level of idiot,
when they get drunk,
it becomes really boring because it becomes,
oh,
you're not really good at this.
Oh,
I see what we're doing.
So we're going to,
we're,
we're going to do here is we're going to play a game that you suck at.
It's like two fat guys playing basketball.
Neither one of them have any experience.
Bounce it around looking stupid.
And,
and for a person that can communicate well and is sober,
it's a real problem.
It's,
you're dragging me into the mud.
You want to say to them,
look at the top of your game.
I struggle to find you.
Interesting.
Now you're drunk.
But then towards counter point is some people are cool as fuck when they're
drunk.
Some people are fun to talk to when they're drunk,
they tell you hilarious stories and they flow good.
It just loosens him up enough so they can catch a wave.
Yeah.
You don't judge yourself as much.
So the rail,
you can come out.
Yeah,
you can catch a wave and if you can catch like one of those social waves,
it can be really fun.
And then you've got to maintain that wave correctly.
Correct.
You have to know don't underfeed it.
Don't overfeed it.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's a tricky thing,
man.
Drinking correctly is like something so much teach you.
Yeah.
I really envy you because you seem to really enjoy it when I see you do it,
but yet you don't have to do it all at a time.
That must be so nice.
Yeah.
I,
and I recognize that it's most likely a genetic thing.
The most of my friends
father died at 53.
He was an alcoholic,
three out of four of my grandparents,
all my aunts and uncles.
And there's so much evidence as far as like American Indians who didn't have a
ta and exposure to
La.
It's also their livers and Irish livers.
Process of alcohol better.
Yeah.
Well because they have a long history of use.
What happened with the native Americans is they weren't drinking as much alcohol
and not nearly as much as westerners that came here.
So when they introduced it to them,
this is like a drug they had no social experience with,
which is always a big one,
you know?
So maybe it's like,
remember when you were a teenager,
the first time you got drunk,
how terrible you were at.
It takes a long time to know where your tolerances are,
how to do it,
how not to be a sloppy bitch.
It takes a while.
Fit shots in general are not a good idea.
Yeah.
When you just go straight to hard liquor and you're 30 and you've been eating
fucking deer that you chase down and killed.
Right.
Peo,
yeah.
And all.
And then all of a sudden you're just drowning in whiskey and they,
you have no experience,
no cultural experience to fall back on.
Oh,
Grandpa told me what this was about.
When you get drunk,
which you've got to do is start off slow.
Boy,
make sure you got food in your stomach that's gonna fill.
There's none of that going on.
No one even knows what the fuck it is.
Yeah.
And then the white man forces it on them because they realize that pliant they
become when they're drunk.
Yeah.
So it was like,
we'll pay you in whiskey and then sign this fucking treaty.
Give me New York for a nickel.
A lot of,
a lot of bad real estate deals were done drunk,
whether it's at a high class hotel and you know,
Donald Trump just fucking sauced you up or you're an Indian.
Well,
how much did they pay for Alaska?
Was that a good deal?
Where'd they buy from?
The Russians believe they bought it from the Russians.
The Russians like,
listen,
we've got more than we can handle.
You want to take that spot right?
Good.
Take that spot.
And when you look at a map,
it's one of the most ridiculous ideas ever that that's somehow or another as a
part of it.
Oh,
no second most ridiculous idea.
Hawaii.
Yeah.
He's pretty ridiculous telling me there's like a hundred countries closer to
Hawaii than the United States.
And we treat it like,
and somehow like,
I don't know the history,
I mean,
it's almost like we sought and we went,
uh,
yeah,
we're going to take that.
And you guys,
you guys can be citizens.
You can vote,
you can come here.
Meanwhile,
we've got Mexico lined up against the board of her.
Like,
you can't fucking come here.
But Hawaiians,
come on.
Well,
Mexico is way bigger.
Hawaii's,
it's just a few little tiny islands and people seem nice and they know how to
cook a pig in the ground.
Let's just fucking work this out.
And that's where the missiles,
have you seen the feed on their women defeat?
Oh,
beautiful.
Little feet.
Yeah.
And they,
they do that.
A Hula dance.
Whoa.
Hey,
hula dance.
Is that what they call it?
Um,
yeah,
isn't it?
I was there,
I suppose skirts,
the grass skirts.
My wife took me to Luau and we were in Hawaii and I fucking,
I hate anything commercial and tourist the,
especially when you're in Hawaii and you're hiking in the rain forest and
fucking serving as,
she's like,
we're going to a Luau.
So,
um,
I was pissed.
So I smoked a joint and not even a joint.
I smoked a couple of heads,
you know what I mean?
And uh,
and then I just fucking sat in the front row of the Luau and you're their feet.
The women's feet were like three feet in front of me,
you know,
they're kind of like rolling on the toes and moving around on them.
I
did.
You get hard.
Yeah.
Wow.
Just by looking at the feet,
you don't like nice fee.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I feel you.
I hear where you're coming from.
It's a weird thing that like,
uh,
we,
we valued that.
Like what is that genetically?
Is that,
what does that to me,
it's that they're hidden.
People wear shoes.
So it's almost like nudity today.
Like,
I'm not supposed to see your little toes and it's,
they move around like fingers,
but they're weird cause she hide them most of the time.
Their fingers at your ride.
I got leather,
the creepy,
right.
I got a massage yesterday and I had my head in the little doughnut thing and I
was looking down and this Asian woman,
she,
she was barefoot and she had I,
I'm sorry,
but Asian feed or better white women's feet are all fucked up.
They're like the,
you know,
one toe is like an inch longer than the other one.
Did you jerk off to this?
Yes.
Right.
Yeah,
I will for sure.
Yeah.
You know what's really sad to me is when women get that thing where their toes
start pointing towards the big toes towards pointing left or right towards the
other toe.
Hammer toe.
Yeah.
From jamming their feet into shoes that just smoosh them.
Well,
it's genetic also.
Is it really?
Yeah.
So you can get it without those shoes,
right?
It's just a bone that grows out and it's like a bone issue.
So the same thing or it can happen both ways.
So either you can get it naturally or you can get it from shoes.
I know you can get it naturally,
but he does.
I've seen it run in families.
You get it from shoes.
I think it's all natural because like I have,
I think some people have like that ridiculous small toe.
Like the retarded toe that goes over got barely has a nail.
The nail.
It's like taking the right turn right turn or it's stacked on the one next door.
Stacked like that.
And I'm like,
why are you wearing flip flops?
Your toe is all fucked up.
Put some shoes on.
I saw this one lady at the beach,
she was this old lady and uh,
she had,
it was,
it was like,
it was a sketch in an in living color moving,
you know,
like her toes were so fucked up.
Like they were going over each other.
I crossing fingers.
I mean I had never seen anything like it.
Yeah.
It was like a,
like a picket fence that got hit
with a missile.
I mean,
the whole thing was just,
it was all just collapsed over itself.
And I like this is the most,
it was like she's throwing gang signs with their feet.
It was one of the most ridiculous things I've ever seen in my life.
Like,
and she's wearing red locks off her feet.
I mean her teeth hurt,
they were tangled.
And it is true.
I think you've got to earn a pair of flip flops.
You got to,
uh,
you got to really take a good look at your feet like an Asian foot.
The toes are,
does a perfect arc.
It's like a 33 degree curvature from the big toe to the pinky.
That pinky is well laid out with a full nail.
There's,
um,
there's no fucking discoloration on the nails themselves,
a thin ankle.
And then you get on a real,
on a good southeastern Asian,
you get like a brownish tannish on the top and then the sides,
it becomes very light,
like almost like a Nilla vanilla wafer.
And uh,
is that from the lack of the will to live?
Hey,
we have a,
we have,
we're wrong.
It's been running.
And Napalm.
Bunyan Bunyan on that Hammertoe is when girls,
the very end of their,
um,
their digit,
they protrude the kind of bulge up right.
That is from shoes.
Got To hammer toe.
That's a different thing kind of Bunyan is when the big tail has a curve on the
side.
Yeah.
The total takes a turn towards the,
towards the other toes,
the big toe hooks,
right or left and it gets worse.
This is actually disagreement among medical medical professionals about the
cause of Bunyan's.
Some see them as primarily caused by longterm use of shoes,
particularly tight fitting shoes with pointed toes.
While other belief,
the problem stems from genetic factors that are exacerbated by shoe use.
Hmm.
Yeah.
You know,
could be very possibly it's,
I would tend to think that it might be shoes because uh,
I think it's way more on women that I see it on men.
I cannot believe women put on those stiletto type shoes.
I mean,
I like it,
but I look at them and I go,
man,
what a,
what a price to pay all.
Like,
even when I'm out at a club all night,
my feet are fucking tired.
I'm wearing sneakers.
And then to think that you're perched up on this thing that your toes are jammed
into and you're at a 45 degree angle,
it's just,
it's really archaic to me.
It's crazy.
Well,
Brian,
what was that last one?
The woman had like fingers for toes.
Would it pull that video back on again?
That was ridiculous.
That's how black women,
black women grow.
They showed three seconds ago was like,
I can find it.
Boss can get some other the do it,
man.
Black women tend to grow.
There we go.
So what the fuck,
man,
listen,
I don't want to see this.
Some guys are into,
I want to see some dude.
She just came from the gym or like they walk in dirt and really guys let them,
yeah,
they liked that.
Hey,
come on for real.
I don't want to see this,
but the,
um,
black women tend to grow the big toenail longer,
which bothers me.
Sexy.
Do you like that case?
They want to snort some coke off
and I'll let you know.
They're ready to party.
Yo Baby,
you want to tell blast?
Have you ever seen the photo where a woman and African American woman has a
gigantic toenails?
All of them.
And it says ghettos.
They do.
You never seen that look up ghettos?
Yes.
Wait,
no,
no.
That's not what we're looking at.
Look,
there's images do a Google image search.
He's just trying to sneak in.
Dude's sucking on total creep.
But Duncan Trussell said the funniest fucking thing the other day.
He was a joking around about someone,
someone,
uh,
who is attractive but was mean.
It was saying something stupid on Fox News and he was like,
she goes,
stop talking and just put your feet in my mouth.
I'm telling you crying,
laughing on the phone.
[inaudible] that's ghettos.
Okay.
Can you mention here at this walking like on a wooden floor?
Just the sound of her nails hitting my could.
It'd be hot.
No one she's about a foot fetish is going to take off.
And I believe it started with me.
I've been talking about the two years publicly.
Oh.
[inaudible] been around for a long time.
Been around.
I'm talking about it going mainstream and talking about it longer than two
years,
man,
maybe five.
Have you ever had a foot in you,
Greg?
Now
one of the Times that we did your serious show,
you were,
you were talking about having a foot foot and it was a long time
and the funny thing is I don't act on it.
Like I,
I've never,
I've never liked sucked on someone's toes and it's just,
I enjoy looking at them.
So do you enjoy looking at them in real life?
As much as on video or on video?
More than real life.
Which one?
In real life?
I'm on the lookout all the time.
All the time.
She just store the memories.
I'm looking down a lot and I,
here's what I also do,
if I see a woman I predict in my head whether she has open toed sandals and what
the feet are going to look like and I'm,
I'm pretty right on it.
If a woman has like really pretty feet,
will you store that and then jerk off to them later?
No,
never.
I can't store shit for jerk off.
I need immediate high center
right in front of you.
Right.
There's never been a time where you took a few days off and you really had a
build up?
Nope.
No.
Now when I only watched foot porn because I'm friends with gross shit,
man affected pus coming down.
What I want to say that I only watched it because Bella,
Donna is a friend of mine and she,
you know,
she does a six foot foot foot soldiers as her whole.
She singled her.
She just got single no shit that maybe that's not known,
but wow,
that's a good news.
Yeah.
Her husband's a good dude,
but he managed so that's always a bad thing.
He what?
He managed her,
which is always a bad thing.
It's a tough sell.
Right?
Yeah.
That's so strange.
It happened with Tara Patrick and that due to the rocker dude.
Yeah.
It was in all of our porn.
He was bad news.
Fascinating when?
When guys like,
not like Mary a porn star,
but she still works,
but no,
he fucks her and all the films,
like a couple of mainstream.
Yeah.
You know who he's with now.
He's with that little loop.
Hey girl,
they drill a peanut like within,
within a month that he broke up a terror.
Patrick,
he's with another porn star managing her and likes it crazy.
Yeah.
Does he only banger or does she bang other dudes?
I have no idea how to talk.
It's tricky.
He yelled at me cause I w I cohosted the porn awards with Tara Patrick.
So I went to her house one time and he was there and I asked him,
I go,
so are you allowed to fuck around?
He's like,
no I don't.
He goes,
this one massage place I go to right over here in the valley.
And uh,
you know,
I get jerked off at the end,
but that's it.
And he's like in goes there from massages too.
And I was like,
you know,
that ain't fucking true.
But that was their press release on the issue.
Who Cares?
That could easily be true.
That could be true.
I did it with my ex.
We both went to the same at the same time.
Why did I do get mad at you?
Cause I said to LoopPay because I noticed that she was back in town.
I was like,
Hey,
I would really like to get you on a that that podcast I do with Dan and Dearman
a triple x squad.
And uh,
he wrote back,
look,
mother Fucker,
I told you she does not want to do your stupid shit,
blah,
like just start going off on me like five tweets.
And then I wrote back something like,
Dude,
sorry,
just asked her if she wanted to do a podcast,
I would help her out.
And then like all these people on Twitter just started like going,
what the fuck?
It was like six months ago.
And then he eventually apologized,
sent me a direct message like,
sorry man,
here's my email address and blah,
blah,
blah.
I thought you were somebody else.
Oh.
And I think some guy,
I think he gets,
she gets harassed a lot by him.
Of course.
She knows man.
Just being,
of course.
Could you imagine being a porn star on the Internet and having everyone just be
able to tweet you?
Yeah.
Oh,
the fucking shirt for women must have to deal with.
Yeah.
Because of the sexual repression that we have.
Like they take the brunt of it.
Like,
like if anybody in this country,
it's,
if you're allowed to call them a slut or a cunt,
it's like a porn star.
It's like the things that guys say to porn.
I've seen some of this shit guys have said to porn.
So I was like,
well,
will yield some girl being your feed complaining.
Like it's,
it's hard to believe some of the fucking creeps that tweet me.
And then,
you know,
and then you'll go to her Twitter page and see her responding.
Then you read the things that they're saying mean fucking heartless,
creepy shit that you're
exactly,
you're only allowed to see in their mind.
Like it's,
it's rare that I think a girl,
like,
let's pick a name of a famous actress who's feel around who's on Twitter though.
Jenny McCarthy.
Jenny McCarthy gets hate because of like the,
the virus thing,
right?
A vaccination thing.
Or she gets a lot of heat because of that.
I just read some whole article about this.
Uh,
this the doctor was actually reading an article about how unfair it is and how
much a heat she takes for having a controversial assessment on,
uh,
on vaccination.
Yeah.
I think that it was irresponsible
for her.
It's a very responsible,
but it's also what she really believed.
You know,
she really believes that at the time,
you know,
I don't know if she still does,
but then I looked up all the things that have been caused by vaccinations and
that's where it's another one of those abortion type things.
It's like vaccinations for sure are not just beneficial.
They probably extended the life of many people in this country.
They've stopped diseases like polio,
nip that shit.
Right.
Basically in the bud,
you know,
stopped measles in bump mumps in a lot of places because of it.
I'm a firm believer,
don't get me wrong,
but people have been damaged by vaccines.
That's a fact too.
It's a small percentage and most scientists believe that it's worth the risk.
But there's people that have been damaged by vaccines that are no longer on the
market and no longer available.
Right.
Glaxo Smith Klein used to have a vaccine for Lyme disease,
but the problem is if you have,
you're only,
you can only,
you only safely can take this vaccine.
If you have a certain gene or if you're lacking a certain gene and they have to
run this like Jean examination on you.
They have to find out what it is.
I'm sorry for butchering this,
but my friend's dad got Lyme disease from the fucking vaccine.
They were going to,
they were going to be hiking.
They're going to live in Connecticut though.
He took it preemptive.
You took it preemptively and it gave him fucking Lyme disease and all of a
sudden the guy's like,
bones
heard.
He came to you is is the most poorly prescribed a disease you can get.
They,
they can go after it with cycle after cycle of hardcore antibiotics as sometimes
they're just chasing it and they can't get it and it fucks you up.
They,
they've,
they need a lot of research on that because it's getting worse.
You know,
the first case of it was less than 20 years ago,
is that right?
Yes.
In Lyme,
Connecticut.
Lyme disease is reported Lyme disease,
I believe less than 21 years old.
Wow.
I think they had never had it before or was undiagnosed before or it mutated.
No one knows exactly,
but it's also connected to this weird thing called [inaudible].
Have you ever heard of more general ones?
It's one of the things that we investigated on the pot on this a Scifi show.
And what was interesting about it was doctors dismiss it right away.
Like you tell someone about more Jones.
I talked to like a really smart doctor.
Like what do you think about more jealous?
I like,
ah,
more challenge.
You know,
those people are kind of crazy.
And I had been to a more Jones conference and I talked to doctors who have more
challenge.
And one of the weird things is that almost all of them also have Lyme disease.
So this Lyme disease,
when ticks are such nasty cunts that they have a host of pathogens that they
carry with them.
Lyme disease being one of them.
But there may be a bunch of undiagnosed tag alongs and more jealous might be one
of these.
He's poor fucking people,
man.
They helped us of it.
First of all,
it makes you crazy.
There's,
it fucks with your head.
The lymes disease.
Does that taste neurological?
Yes,
it uh,
it,
it hurts their,
the way they look at the world.
And one of the doctors that I talked to was talking to me about neuro toxicity,
about how it has a certain amount of neuro toxicity.
We go pretty deep into it on this show.
Um,
it's,
it's incredibly fast
and meanwhile we don't fucking need deers while other being carried now in mice
as much as dear dog
to,
you know,
the people who have never been around a,
an area where this is a real issue,
would never understand it.
But like upstate New York,
it's a real fucking problem.
Like how many deer?
A lot of deer and they carry ticks and those ticks get on people and you get
Lyme disease and you're fucked and you,
you know,
you like bright lights hurt,
your joints hurt.
Like it couldn't fucking sleep.
My aunt got it.
And she had to go in once a week for antibiotics.
And,
uh,
she got diabetes from it,
a whole list of shit plus extreme exhaustion.
She could,
she would be up six,
seven hours a day.
And so,
you know what got rid of it?
What a hysterectomy.
Oh my God.
She needed a hysterectomy.
And so she got it.
And then they found her Lyme disease was gone a few months ago and the doctor
went,
oh yeah,
yeah,
that happens.
And she's like,
so for 10,
15 years I've been walking around exhausted in pain,
getting disease.
And as a woman who was,
you know,
50 obviously not having more kids and the doctor didn't bring up that
hysterectomy would get rid of this disease.
How does the hysterectomy get rid of the disease?
I think it changes your estrogen levels or something.
Wow.
I don't know exactly.
Uh,
and again,
I always have to do a preamble when I do any sort of a recorded spoken thing.
Um,
I don't know.
As much as I say I do.
So many times I will put out information that's wrong,
but I will do it with full confidence.
So yeah.
So if you want to Google this entire interview,
you will find,
uh,
no less than three major errors in what I've said.
And if you want to tweet me about it,
it's at Greg Fitz show,
point them out.
And I will acknowledge like Sunday [inaudible] who's a doctor,
Sanjay Gupta.
I will admit I was wrong.
Let's beautiful.
Greg.
Why not?
Why I changed my mind on weed by Sanjay Gupta.
Oh,
by the way,
can I plug my dates?
Yeah.
When are you a,
somewhere I'm going to be coming up in a standup live.
Do you know the club in Phoenix?
Arizona price is huge when either,
well,
I'm there next week.
It'll be August,
uh,
15 through 17,
15 to 17.
And uh,
yeah,
I just booked the date a couple weeks ago,
so I need,
I need the fucking [inaudible] squad people let me know.
I'll tweet,
tweet something to me.
I'll tweet it.
I will.
And then I have a one hour special on comedy central coming out on August 18th
at midnight.
Did you film it?
Tarrytown,
New York,
where?
I grew up as a theater from 85
wow.
That was in disrepair when I was growing up.
So it used to be a movie theater.
I went to see fucking Herbie the love bug there and then they restored it and
it's this,
it's got like all the orange h shit and the balcony and it's credible.
So it was like my family was there,
my friends and Westchester just fucking turned out.
Kids I went to grammar school with in high school and college.
It was an amazing night.
Really Magic.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
You really getting into doing stand up again.
Like you really love it.
And again,
yeah,
a long time.
You did a lot of writing,
right?
We weren't doing nearly as much stand up now.
And you know it's funny I talked to Dana Gould recently about it cause you know
he took time off entirely.
I mean,
he stopped entirely when he did the Simpsons and now he's back in at the last
five,
six years.
And you know,
as everybody knows,
just one of the most respected comics among comics but does not have the,
the um,
a claim around the country that he should,
because he was,
he stopped the grit.
He stopped when he was like,
he was like really respected when we were coming up.
Right.
He was like,
oh,
special,
great comics.
Just a really an interesting comment.
Right.
You know,
I mean interesting points of view.
Yeah.
And a very unique guy.
He stopped,
it was writing for the Simpsons,
right?
Yeah.
One Amy's made a ton of fucking dope and also like,
you know,
had kids wanting to be around a bit.
So,
um,
so for me,
I feel like I never stopped,
but I was splitting my time.
Like for 12 years I've worked on TV shows every year,
but I've also done on a slow year,
still 12 weekends a year.
And on a good year I'm still,
like this year I'll do 26 weekends.
26 is nice.
That's every two weeks ago on the road.
Yeah.
That's how it should be.
That's good.
That's,
that keeps you from freaking out,
right?
If you're one of those,
maybe when you were 21 you could go on the road for like a month and a half or
two months,
but I can offer those things like let's do a bus tour.
I'm like,
fuck you.
Yeah Dude.
We should do one bus tour for how many of the week do do a week?
We go to fucking Madison,
Wisconsin and Chicago.
Just route it.
So you got like two hours between each gig.
Bill Byrd wanted to do something like that.
He wanted to go to Rick.
Really shitty places.
Yeah.
He like found a bunch of really shitty places.
It to me,
I was like,
I looked at the texts,
I'm like,
bitch,
I ain't going to
places that are not worth going to write.
We could mix it up.
You do a really good city and then you do a small one.
I would do it just to do shows with him.
Yeah.
Or do them with you.
We could do them together.
You,
Brian,
you open your Austin?
I'll do one,
two,
three punch.
I want to do a Dallas,
Houston,
Austin,
like just the dude just go up texting.
I think Dallas and Austin are too much the same market.
They're only an hour away.
No,
they're not the same market.
Now.
A lot of fucking people,
people in Texas will come out.
If you really know Greg Fitzsimmons is only going to be in Austin,
they'll drive from Dallas.
Right?
There's on the same market.
This is,
they're both big ass cities.
There's plenty of people in Austin and plenty of people in Dallas.
Right.
That cap
city in Austin's,
one of the greatest clubs in the history of the world.
It's such a great fucking club.
And the people that run it are cool.
Yeah,
well it's a real,
like they support the art form,
you know,
it's like a legit support of the art form club.
And when I tell a town needs,
you need a club like that and then you need a community and then you know you
need an open Mike night and then boom,
you got it.
Well,
you need a manager that is going to,
you know,
it's the effort to make an open mic night and they don't make money on it.
So it's an investment in the local talent.
Basically.
You're saying,
uh,
you know,
the way the Way San Francisco does in Denver does,
you're saying we're going to have our farm team locally.
We're going to teach guys how to do it on an open mic nights,
support them and make them opening acts when they're good enough.
And then they start to create their own satellite rooms and coffee houses and
whatever.
And then you've got a scene in it and a club owner knows that.
I know this comic,
he knows me.
You see people that go back to the San Francisco Punch line,
myself included,
I go in for way less money than I work anywhere else because it's a small room.
But I fucking do it because I love it.
I love Molly and it's just,
and you're in a city you love and the middle of it.
And so I think that it's smart for club owners to establish these relationships
and give the support to the community because it pays back.
Yeah.
No it does pay back.
It does.
And I think that it's the best way to support stand up and to keep the art form
alive.
Cause it's hard for a person to go from being like just a guy who wants to go on
stage for the very first time say in Indianapolis,
you know,
it's fucking hard.
It's not easy to like develop a comedy career out of there and try to even get
time locally.
It's very difficult unless you're doing your own rooms and then we just start
getting booked nationally.
Good fucking luck.
You have to have some sort of a draw to get booked.
You mean unless you find someone to piggyback with like someone thinks you're
funny that it takes you with him as a middle act or an opening act.
Good fucking luck getting booked anywhere
and you,
you would think,
cause I think for a lot of feature acts,
they come in with somebody with a headliner.
Club owners sometimes resent that and you don't get booked back as a feature.
You think that you're going to showcase for them as a feature for the headliner.
But you know,
depending on the club,
sometimes they would rather book their own features and they,
so they have a chip on their shoulder.
Yeah.
Is that person?
Thomson girl was telling me this story about this,
this guy,
um,
someone couldn't make a show,
so they had to,
uh,
call for a replacement and timeline or use.
Well,
Tom was the headliner and the Middle Act couldn't make it.
And so Tom wanted to use his buddy who's in town and uh,
the manager's like,
no,
no.
I've already got someone coming.
And she's like,
uh,
you know,
I prefer to use them.
And he's like,
but I already,
I'm in touch with this guy.
He's five minutes away.
He can be here.
Well,
it turns out the other guy was someone that she was fucking right.
So she wanted to get her boyfriend to work as the middle,
but he's like,
well,
this is,
do you understand?
This is my show.
Like,
I don't want this guy.
He's terrible.
Yup.
And so Tom was forced to work with this guy.
The last time you worked with him,
he said he did 45 minutes and then was selling tee shirts at the end.
Like had this big pitch for people to go by his shirts and it was like the
grossest thing ever.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
he's gotta fucking work with this guy again.
It's one of the big bummers about doing the road.
If you don't have full control of the show,
it's like you can't,
if you do the road,
like I do the road,
we do the road,
it's all our friends and then it becomes a party.
It's like we,
we might as well if we're in Montreal or if we're in Florida,
it's the same party,
you know,
it's like we're moving all over the place,
but it's the same party
and it forces you to get out of your room and go to a decent restaurant for
dinner and things become more of an event.
Whereas if I'm alone,
yeah.
I,
I will eat at Starbucks breakfast and lunch.
That's how pathetic I am.
It's a very lonely thing working on the road alone for like three or four days
in a row.
It's very lonely.
Yeah,
I like it because,
you know,
like you,
I got kids in the house and even though I have an office,
it's different when I'm on the road,
I fucking,
I get up late,
but I'm awake when I'm up and then I work out and then I listened to my show
from the night before.
I take copious notes and then I work on the set for that night and then I,
we'd all my fucking emails and,
and then I just go to the show like with total focus.
Yeah.
That's a big one man,
that a lot of comics don't like to do,
listening to the show and take notes.
But I have gotten so much out of doing that.
Like that's like one of the best warm ups too for me.
Um,
when I,
uh,
if I'm going to do a show somewhere,
I'll go over all of my notes,
like everything for like,
I'll set aside like two hours where I just go over notes.
Usually the plane ride for me is that it's perfect plane rides.
Perfect.
You're focused,
you're sitting there and not go anywhere and get coffee anytime you want.
Boom.
But going over those notes,
that's number one.
Then listening to a set and like trying to figure out like what order things
should be in or what I I forgot to do or what could be a good tag here.
Like sometimes like you'll have like a little thing in the recording that
becomes this blossom takes off.
It's just one
whatever.
The genesis of the joke was sometimes falls away entirely.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
It's like the the way you get to an idea.
Sometimes it's just like in in that sense it's almost a living thing,
like it's kind of growing and finding its own form as you're working it out on
stage
and it's so subtle that you have to listen to the tape right away because then
you can remember where your energy was at that moment and what thoughts you were
having at that moment.
You can connect it all because the changes are so small
and sometimes you'll hear doors that opened up that you didn't follow through
on.
Thank you.
Like,
oh,
there's another whole bit there.
Oh my God.
Like that happens all the time.
Or you'll go off on a little tangent and you just think after you went off.
Thank God I got that recorded because I don't even remember exactly what
everything,
when I get off stage.
Well people would never know that the weird sort of mindset if,
unless they've done it unless they've tried to do stand up.
But that weird mindset when you're locked in in the groove,
it's almost like you're there and you're,
you're focused and your,
you're in the moment,
but you're also like completely blank and it's all just common out of your mouth
with no,
you know,
you're not clinging on to anything.
It's all just flying out of your mouth.
You're locked into it.
And it's almost like being a passenger in that sense.
Yeah.
You're,
you're an active passenger.
It's almost like,
um,
I guess like sports when you know,
when you know the fundamentals well enough that you let go and you find,
what do they call it,
the zone.
You're doing the zone and uh,
and it because you're so in the moment,
you don't have that perspective of later on remembering what exactly you said
and then you listen to it.
I'll listen to it on tape and completely forget that I,
that I went into this place or somebody from the audience yell something out.
And I think,
um,
you and I are similar.
I don't go counter when somebody yells something out.
I try to take it and use it if I possibly can.
And sometimes it's fucking great because it came out of,
they were in the moment too when they yelled something.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's such a fun balance.
Like sometimes it's not a problem at all when people yell out something in the
right time.
Right.
And sometimes it's like a huge problem because you get one idiot who won't stop
doing it.
Right.
And he's annoying everyone around them.
It's,
it's almost like it's a very fine line you walk cause occasionally someone will
yell something and it's hilarious.
Well especially if it's clearly when you're between bits.
Yes,
that's right.
Yelling out that I've gone and get a sip of water.
You yell at an idea.
But if I'm like that abortion bit,
I'll fucking set that thing up.
Which is,
that's a,
that's a 9.8 difficulty level doing an abortion joke that's pro a pro life
somewhat.
And you build it up and it's fragile man.
You're standing on a house of cards cause you haven't gotten to the laugh yet.
And then someone yells something and you want to go out and punch him in the
face because now you got to,
you got to lose.
Yeah.
That,
that'd becomes a real problem when people just can't keep quiet long enough to
let someone do their thing.
It's also like the combative nature of people when it comes to controversial
ideas because the ideas become very,
the become very emotionally invested in the ideas,
whether if it's abortion or a war or being a Vegan.
And a lot of times you'd get that same sort of reaction.
So it's not just a matter of being attached to the idea,
it's being emotionally connected to that idea of succeeding and that,
you know,
you being against that idea,
they'll in your face and screaming and pointing fingers.
Yeah.
You know,
becomes a weird human characteristic.
That's a,
uh,
an unfortunate aspect of people when it comes to certain ideas.
It says like,
it's a,
there's a,
I mean,
I've felt it myself.
There's like a natural inclination to stay competitive.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And um,
it sort of feels like when you go to that place and you're trying to be at the
same time,
you want to say to the audience,
Hey,
listen,
I'm not a professor at a university.
You're paying tuition at,
I'm not a speaker on NPR.
I'm,
uh,
I tell Dick Jokes in front of drunks.
And if you,
if you have to challenge what I'm saying,
you're,
you're really taking everything too seriously.
But there is a point though,
as an audience member where we've all seen this one guy who goes on stage and
it's just essentially preaching,
right?
I mean,
we've all seen that and it gets to be this,
you know,
women should be the only ones.
You get to choose what they do and don't do to their body.
And they're like pace in the stay away from making laws break after.
And the problem is these points to me,
or Duh,
yeah,
of course they should of course murder's it bad.
Of course you shouldn't rob people.
Of course you shouldn't kick babies.
Of course.
Duh.
You don't have to say that.
I mean,
in my world,
you don't have to say those things.
In my world,
those things are a given.
So let's start there.
Right?
You don't have to just preach some really obvious shit that everyone's gonna
fucking agree with.
And also to me it's like if you're doing a joke that is about an issue that's
about gun control,
that you're,
you're about gun control.
Do what joke about a detail that you have a point of view on.
Don't announce we are now going to take on gun control and here's my take on it.
To me it's like bury that.
Yeah.
And it's also,
I want to hear about it from a guy like you who I know is doing the work.
I know that if you're going to go on stage,
you have my full confidence that if you're going to present an idea on state,
especially a very controversial one,
like a pro life sort of a pro,
a pro fetus,
sort of an argument in a joke form like,
Woo,
I know that you have put together a little dance,
right,
and I have to wash this dance completely play out
and then I may have some turns in it.
Exactly.
But that,
that knee jerk thing where people attach themselves to ideas of it.
You're talking about abortion or you talking about it almost like they get a
green light to be a dick.
This guy's an asshole.
Green Light,
no wrong,
not true propaganda,
liberal,
you know,
whatever.
Whatever they want to say to you.
Whatever.
I was in Lake Tahoe and I was talking about how we've been brainwashed to
support billionaires in this country and in every other society when this few
people had this much of the money,
they were dragged in the straight,
had their heads chopped off when we split their shit and we should start killing
billionaires.
Well,
it's obviously a ridiculous bit,
but it's based in a feeling that I have of resentment of these people.
Right?
Clearly a comedic extrapolation on a,
on an idea and a,
this dude fucking stands up in a casino and re in Lake Tahoe walks towards the
stage screaming at me that I'm a,
that I'm a socialist,
which by the way,
I am.
I do believe we should share the shit more.
So he walks up and somebody grabs him from coming up on stage and so,
and I just keep baiting him.
Now I'm like,
I want this motherfucker on stage so bad I am getting in his head.
I'm making him implode.
So then they have to drag him out as soon as he gets thrown out,
no other dude in the back row is up.
He's pacing back and forth and I do the same thing.
I just looked at him,
I go,
that's right.
I'll kill him.
My bare fucking ads.
I'll pull them out of a Ferrari and a,
and they just keep going and,
and it was like does instinct,
I had to create chaos because they,
they are not going to take my show no matter what it takes.
If I'm on a stage,
that's my fucking stage and I will,
I will burn the place down before you take it.
Controlling my shell.
It becomes a real issue with folks who are not familiar with your material,
that just going out to a quote unquote comedy show that's a casino.
Yeah.
That's the problem is there's going to be a big difference between that and who
comes to see you at the Bray Improv,
for example.
You know,
most likely there's going to be Greg Fitzsimmons fans are going to come,
they're going gonna know what you do and they're gonna enjoy it.
But when you,
when someone's just going out to see comedy and you're giving them some really
heavy duty subversive shit wrapped up and sarcasm and it's like what?
It's like they're a little feeble.
Brains can't handle it.
Right,
right.
And Til billionaires,
what the fuck?
You know,
billionaires made this fucking country what it is because they believe they're
going to be one.
Yeah.
It's always broke.
People who they were like,
what is that about?
Boy Did they fucking,
boy,
they do a brainwash job on them.
That is why I applaud the Republican party because I should say just to conserve
as in general,
the,
the mind control that they have pulled off and now the Koch Brothers just
purchased like 11 and Tribune newspapers,
like big ones.
That shouldn't be a problem.
Right.
What's,
what's it sounded like Rupert Murdoch editorialized news at all.
[inaudible] own coca cola by the way.
The Koch now there's no,
it's into a textile.
Think what's fascinating too about the idea of someone getting upset,
like a,
a poor person getting upset about,
you know,
about billionaires and like calling you a socialist or calling you a communist.
Like you're the people that would benefit the most from this not being the case.
Like this idea,
pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
Those guys almost never do because the billionaires,
if they're in a situation in,
in you,
you're saying something disagree with,
they don't stand up and scream.
They get the fuck out of there.
Right.
You know why?
Because they don't want anybody knowing they're a billionaire.
When you,
you're a fucking billionaire and you're just walking around,
you're like a bank on wheels,
right?
You can't just go places,
you know,
you can't like Oprah Winfrey.
Do you think Oprah Winfrey,
you can just go places everywhere.
Oprah goes,
you must have some sort of protection with her.
She must have some big men and cars that ricochet bullets off of main.
Do you know how many lawsuits are filed?
Like I talk,
I'm not going to say who,
but it really,
really rich famous prison fucking 14 lawsuits at that time against them.
Wow.
Because it's,
it's why wouldn't you?
You have any contact with this person that doesn't go well,
fuck it.
You know,
they'll settle out of court.
I'll grab a couple of hundred thousand dollars.
What happened,
uh,
with Oprah Winfrey recently,
she said that she was subjected to racism while shopping in Switzerland.
She's former talk show host tells entertainment tonight.
She was in a zoonotic store when she asked an employee if she could examine a
large purse.
According to Winfrey,
the employee repeatedly refused saying that the purse was too expensive.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
The employer told her,
no,
you don't want to see that one.
You want to see this one because that one cost too much.
We won't be able to afford that.
And I don't want to hurt your feelings.
Well,
those are the whitest people in the world.
But could you imagine what a colossal fuck up it is to say that to Oprah Winfrey
bad for the country?
Well,
Jay sucked it up for their whole country.
Stomp and think just for a moment of all the people that you didn't think was
rich,
right?
Oprah fucking Winfrey.
She's one of the richest humans that have ever walked the face of the planet
with one of the biggest platforms to communicate what you just did on the
planet.
Unbelief,
I mean is,
I mean how many women are richer than Oprah Winfrey,
especially like self-made without,
there's a woman in Australia who I think is the richest person in Australia and
she's,
she's worth it
more than Oprah.
She wanted to buy for Tina Turner,
so it's a double whammy.
You know,
God,
she was in Switzerland for Tina Turner's wedding,
just trying to buy a beautiful purse.
Wow.
That's fucking crazy.
Crazy.
What a dummy it gets.
That's a racist thing.
I,
when I,
when I first heard about it and I was like,
oh,
come on,
it's probably not racist.
That is a hundred percent racist.
When I first heard about it,
this is how fucking gross I am.
I immediately dismissed it.
I was like,
Eh,
racism.
She recommends that plane and your Roper Winfrey.
Right?
And then I went,
oh,
then you actually read the story and you go,
Oh yeah,
that's racism.
That's it.
That isn't this a fucking store.
There's a store,
right,
and you're selling shit and someone wants to see it because they want to buy it.
And you're like,
no,
not you.
Yeah,
but what if like a white woman came like two minutes later and they said,
she's like,
no,
this is too expensive.
You can look at why do they have the person that should be something you have to
get a meeting with.
You have to like put down a credit card.
It's probably some kind of,
you know,
might be that expensive where they're like,
it's not even really for sale.
It's just like this to happen.
It's a purse or needs a shit to happen because her life is so insulated.
Like you said,
there's always bodyguards around.
He can't just walk out.
She doesn't get shit like that,
that she can then go on TV and talk about she loved.
Yet you think she's not looking for that?
Not to dismiss it.
I'm with you gel.
This is racism.
But her fucking twat wedded up when this happened.
Did you hear what Chung's a daughter called Oprah and she was very rude.
Tommy Chong Chong
defended,
or did he really?
Yeah,
there's a video of him just saying,
you know,
like she would be,
well,
what she said was about that Oprah would be the first person to run to the most
powerful person in the room and kiss their ass and become their best friend.
And you know,
does he know,
I think she called her,
she did just did a movie with her and I think she called her a house and word of
field and we owe a field and word.
Yeah.
That worse than a House Edward?
Yeah,
outside.
Yeah.
It's not even in the house.
It's the house ones.
I think that we're seen as more compromise by the white man.
Oh,
okay.
Awesome.
That makes sense.
Well,
yeah,
then it's even then it's mean,
and then when she says to me that she used to sell out to white people,
how can you be upset about someone who's a slave?
That doesn't even make sense.
It's funny because you have white people that black audiences and nobody calls
them a sell out.
That's true,
right?
Yeah.
Or there's no,
or what about white people with white audiences?
Right.
You know,
if any,
just because she's black and she has a white audience,
like so fucking what does a lot of black woman like her too?
She obviously taps into a vein.
It's not my vein.
It's not your vein and it's the on it.
Yeah,
but guess what?
The people are different than you and I,
it's nothing wrong with that.
Like I like Oprah.
I think Oprah is like a really positive person,
which she promotes to me despite the fact that she's like a super billionaire,
she promotes to me is that you could think positive,
you can make shit happen,
you could do things.
You'd be nice to people like you could promote good causes.
She said food,
she's at multinational corporation and she chooses to spend a lot of that money
on schools in Africa,
learning programs here.
She's a role model for women and black people and she interviews a lot.
She did.
I mean,
she had a lot of like gossipy sort of interviewed,
especially back in the day,
like bill burr had a great joke about her,
like how she actually made her career.
You know,
about like she can't get all high and mighty now because we remember how you got
there in the first place.
So she had like a crazy Maury Povich type show.
Right.
You know,
if you go to get that one,
we,
I was hanging out with al magical is when the first time I ever met them.
When Al was a,
uh,
he was the host at the old cops.
Do you remember the old cops?
Right?
Did you ever do it?
Yeah,
it's like a hundred.
I was there the night it burned down.
I was on stage when it burned down.
Right.
Oh my God.
How many seats was that?
1005020520 five what a great room you were there.
Actually,
when the fire broke out,
right?
Firemen ran in and told everybody to get out of the building.
Helmets on access.
People ran out.
There was fucking shit caught the buildings,
holy shit in the street.
And I watched the thing burned to the ground.
It was crazy what started that fire next door was a hotel they were renovating
and it was like an oily rag kind of thing.
And then it crossed over cause it was called the cannery and it was,
it's an old,
you know,
walkway with the building's pretty close together.
And you know those San Francisco buildings or from like the 1820s and always
been,
the problem with San Francisco is that there's a fire.
All buildings are connected.
Like a lot of those buildings on those hills,
windy.
So it's blowing the flame and it's hills.
So everything goes up.
It's like,
I mean it's the,
they have terrible fires.
The um,
earthquake and fire,
what was it like the 18 hundreds then they have that other one in [inaudible]
94.
Right.
There were some fires at attached to that one too,
wasn't there?
No,
no.
89.
Right.
It was at 89,
I think that was the earthquake.
Canadian.
I wasn't where they got hit really hard.
It was that [inaudible] 91.
Um,
they usually by earthquake and fire during the world series.
Serious fuck.
Yeah,
that's right.
I remember that.
That was nuts.
Yeah.
That's a crazy place to live.
San Francisco's up bad ass city though.
I,
I was there without magical and we just worked together and we were smoking pot
with him and his friends and we're sitting in his parents house.
His parents had this dope house on the hill and we were watching Oprah Winfrey
old school,
Oprah Winfrey,
and I'll never forget,
I like,
we were sitting there,
I was looking the first time it's ever met Al,
and we'll watch that show.
And we were like,
damn,
look how crazy hope or at least to look,
she had this crazy hair and she was interviewing Liza racists,
like these real,
like heavy duty white supremacists.
And it wasn't like the chastising holier than now Oprah of today.
It was like the scared Oprah who's like just starting to,
was like a,
almost like a newspaper report,
you know,
or a news camera,
newscaster,
it wasn't like the confident,
powerful,
iconic figure.
Oprah.
It was weird.
It's like the wow,
this woman,
like she worked her way up.
Yes.
She became like a lioness.
She became more graceful and powerful as she got older.
And uh,
it's still forgets you won an Oscar for color purple.
Yeah,
no shit.
She,
um,
I mean if you stop and think about it like how many other women who've ever done
like that and like risen to that level,
they get close and then they fucking,
they Rosie O'Donnell lit.
This is right.
I mean,
Alan,
Alan looked like she was going there and then the show kind of flat lined a
little bit.
I mean,
I think it's a successful show,
but it didn't,
it didn't grow into the empire that open
for has Rosie had a good show on the Oprah Winfrey network,
but the,
for whatever reason,
TV show or radio show,
she was a TV show.
I did it.
Oh yeah,
she's in Chicago,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
She was brutal boss.
I know some people that worked on that show.
Really?
Apparently they just cleaned house one day.
Everybody.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
She's a tough boss.
Well now that she's a lesbian,
she's like a dude,
right?
Lesbian.
That's what I've heard.
No,
Rosie O'donnell.
Oh fuck.
I'm sorry.
Who are you talking about?
Oprah.
Oh,
no,
no.
I thought you were talking about Rosie.
Rosie is a yes,
I believe at a lesbian.
So powerful lesbian.
Yeah,
I did.
She had a big conspiracy theorist.
Hey Shea.
Oh yeah.
Tower seven tower seven.
I just watched another tower,
seven video with Ed Asner.
I was like,
all right.
if ed as nurses now that they're getting involved with tower seven videos and
it,
you know,
it was like there's,
it was the most legit tower seven video.
I saw it as there's onboard.
Yeah.
And Wow,
but it's still,
it's like they talk about the,
they always like the,
the whole video is very believable.
They,
they'd never talked about the humongous chunk of building that was missing on
one side.
You know,
like they always,
they always talk about,
well this is like impossible cause the other,
you know,
this happened and this happened the way it melted.
Yeah.
There's like there's no office fire that's ever been taken down though,
you know,
building and how the columns like you know,
just one was damaged in that that made everyone all of the money.
But they also don't talk about the big,
humongous whole that's missing in the building.
Not once in that video.
Who did they talk about the big hole in the middle of the road and you're taking
the towers
that was most certainly a giant hole and diesel fires through the whole
building.
That said,
I have never seen a building collapse into its foundation like that.
That wasn't a controlled demolition.
Right.
It doesn't mean that it can't happen because obviously I'm not an architect,
but I know that they have that architects and engineers from nine 11 truth.
This is like 2000 people involved in that second.
They all have a,
this belief that that would have never happened under natural circumstances,
but how many,
but out of those 2000 how many more thousands?
Disagree?
I don't know that.
I don't have that information.
I [inaudible] believe that,
but it might be 150,000 think it's nonsense.
Because of x or y?
Well the government pointed to this,
uh,
or might've commissioned a popular mechanics,
I believe,
did the definitive report which said that,
you know,
everything was legit,
but that felt,
that felt a little too neat.
Yeah.
That's a hurst publication man.
William Randolph first,
the same guy made marijuana illegal.
That's the same guy who put pate stories.
I mean,
Hurst publication in 1930.
Yeah,
30,
whatever it was,
35 or something like that.
I mean he,
he put in,
uh,
stories about these blacks and Mexicans raping,
raping white women because they got hooked on this marijuana.
Right.
That's where the term marijuana came from.
Before that,
marijuana was a slang for a wild Mexican tobacco.
No,
Shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's a bad motherfucker.
It was all because of hemp hemp,
the commodity.
He was going to have to switch to paper over who's going to switch his paper
over to him because hemp is a superior paper.
And uh,
he was going to have to switch,
hit forests that he would chop down and make trees out of it.
Cause he had paper mills because he not only had newspapers,
you also had paper mills.
So in this battle over the commodity of him,
he demonized it as being connected to this drug that was making black and
Mexicans rape white women.
Right.
And then in 1970 they commissioned a big study the government did and then they,
I think they made it
another law or,
well,
1970 was a sweeping psychedelic act that made everything illegal category
Western drugs,
everything.
Because yeah,
actually what's really fascinating is the category one,
drugs are less dangerous in a lot of ways.
Then category two drugs,
like category one is marijuana,
but to schedule two is cocaine and heroin because they're considered less
addictive.
No,
they're way more addictive.
Way More dangerous.
Way more toxic.
LD 50 rate's much higher or much lower with lethal dose at 50%.
Like you could kill yourself pretty easy on either one of those heroin,
cocaine,
nobody
marijuana if time has ever oded on marijuana.
Exactly.
Marijuana is not gonna kill you.
So the idea that one of them is a schedule one,
which is marijuana,
which is the most illegal.
And those two are scheduled to is one of the kookiest filling of those crazy.
And also in this,
and this we'd movie,
um,
gooped at talks about how the level of addiction with marijuana was way
overstated.
And every new study shows that it's like a 10% rate as opposed to like a 30 or
40% rate with heroin and cocaine.
And there's people that are addicted to everything.
You can get into that until the sun comes on.
There's people that are addicted to playing online poker,
physically addictive.
I've been addicted to playing video games.
I know that feeling.
It is very much like an addiction.
It's a compulsive gnawing away at your consciousness feeling.
And that could happen with almost anything can certainly happen.
But psychological versus physiological,
psychological versus physiological and psychological is a real issue.
It's a real issue.
But it's an issue for almost everything that exists.
And when you're dealing with giant numbers,
like how many people smoke marijuana?
Jesus Christ,
you're talking about millions and millions and millions of fucking people in
this country.
Millions.
So out of those you're going to get a couple of losers.
Okay.
You're going to get a few people that can't keep the shit together.
You're going to get a few people that would have fallen off the rails.
It was sniffing glue or huffing Doritos.
Yeah.
So is it tricky for even intelligent people?
Certainly can be conditions.
Very biology varies but for the most part we've been sold a package shit.
Yeah.
And uh,
and it feels pile of shit and it feels like I'm,
the tide is changing,
right?
I mean it's a yes,
this was a big one.
Yeah.
This is huge.
That Sanjay Gupta,
that's the guy who was also accused of being a shill because he was getting paid
millions of dollars by or thousands of dollars.
Excuse me.
I'm an exaggerated thousands of dollars by the pharmaceutical companies.
So blood pressure medication or something.
I don't know what it was.
But Dr drew apparently it got it got a little cash on a sack too.
You know,
dog lucky man.
Hang just running shit on TV for my own personal benefit.
I got to wet.
I Bake motherfucker love,
nice cause dog.
I like pretty shiny shit.
Give the doctor tastes.
Now,
I don't think there's anything wrong with the good doctor getting consultations
or giving consultations are making some money.
Nothing wrong with that.
It's just like it's against the hippocratic oath.
But when it isn't,
I would think so.
I mean,
they're supposed to,
they're supposed to be as neutral as possible.
If scientists,
and I think if they're dispensing advice that can affect your life,
your health,
but,
but these people have taken an oath,
surely they would only do good.
And just the fact that this company's making them hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year,
that doesn't mean that they'd be willing to say things they wouldn't ordinarily
say it's true.
They would only sign on for the ones that they absolutely believe that's the
only way they do it.
Right.
Some doctors role doctors are different than all other people
that have ever existed in fact,
and judges,
yes.
Judges are all completely unaffected by the political party that got them into
office.
Oh,
we're fucked.
It's a stupid system in it.
It's a crazy system.
But,
um,
you know,
it seems to me that this pot thing I feel,
I feel really excited about some of the trends that we're getting with legalized
gay marriage with uh,
you know,
legalized marijuana.
I think these are,
these are big fucking cracks in the,
uh,
in the wall.
I think so too.
I think it's also,
there's an understanding that people are finally getting that we've been sort of
sold this bill of goods that it's conservative versus liberal.
Okay.
Look folks,
when now we have a liberal president and everything is exactly the same.
Exactly.
It's got to stop.
Like at this point in time when a guy who is a fucking half black son of a
single parent,
when that guy is doing the same shit and it's running exactly the same way
horribly wrong,
we've been sold a bill of goods,
right?
We're duking it out with each other over gay marriage and nonsense.
Let's just get married.
Who gives a fuck?
And then I think slowly but surely as people realize that this immediate
connection with homosexual,
we in like liberal De de,
De,
de vi,
something wrong with the way.
Uh,
they're,
they've been raised,
you know,
a delinquent evil and yeah,
Christian aids because they deserved it.
Like these ideas or these are ridiculous and at certain point in time people
going,
oh yeah,
yeah I know.
I decided,
I thought gay people were trying to recruit people.
Like people are slowly starting to like realize that it's stupid.
But if you could put three things on the table that should be dealt with and
talked about and change to be made versus all these window dressing things,
even abortion,
there's are all they affect,
people deal with it,
how they want to deal with them.
What are the things that you think should be in the,
in the public discourse right now?
The biggest one would be people being able to vote on everything.
Everything that gets done,
every war.
Electoral.
Unless it's in,
in,
you know,
immediate defense of life.
You know those situations like Pearl Harbor,
you know,
there'd been attack,
get the boats are there,
shoot back,
and you know,
that type of a scenario.
Everything.
Other than that,
I think there should be an educated discourse and that's the only way that you
have a government that acts in representation of the people itself.
So most people would not be for most of the things that happen,
especially if they were educated about the ramifications.
This is the,
the actual motivation.
Here's the pros and cons.
Here's the conspiracy theory.
If we looked at at all,
like from an educated standpoint,
much less would slip through the cracks,
but because,
and they have to make it easy because what it comes down to is who will be
motivated to actually to the polls and vote.
It's gotta be on your fucking laptop with a code.
You've,
well,
there's votes.
What once a week.
Yeah.
People say that.
Oh,
you can fucking,
someone's going to hack into it.
Guess what else you can do online bank.
Okay.
You can bank online.
It's the nutty that's way nuttier than check left for yes and right for no
putting your money,
your fucking ones and Zeros in some weird account somewhere and moving around.
It's on plastic and you're one through the machine at the gas station that's
fucking way nuttier than voting way daddy act into,
you know,
you look at what they've hacked into with wikileaks online,
they've got national secret,
you know,
nuclear codes are online.
I think about the number of transactions to take place banking wise every day
online and then add to those stock market transactions.
Add to those long people are getting loans online.
You know,
I mean there's,
the amount of transactions that are taking place are fucking staggering.
Trillions probably every day probably.
So that seems like,
yeah,
if you could.
Problem is like with the voting booths,
it turns out there was a Republican,
one of the main Republican fundraisers in Florida was the guy that designed the
voting booths for Florida.
It's like,
all right,
we got to pick a fucking company to set up the software to vote.
That is from Switzerland.
They don't like black people
but they,
they're neutral to us voting well it's just one person.
This is not represent the entire stretchy.
One person fucked up with Oprah,
maybe Oprah of like tries to fuck with people and she goes and gets made up like
go homeless lady puts like a sake scabs.
Yeah.
Yo Yo.
Very obnoxious.
Sort of like,
like a Kung Fu master might,
you know,
pretend to be like a drunk and stumble into a bar to get people to push them
around.
Fuck people up.
I've met people who've done that before.
Maybe that's what Oprah did.
She's leaving out part of this story,
right?
People used to think the ACA get to debt purse.
Oh man,
that person does shit.
Y'All give me a of Rome bow and one of those
purses to imagine if Oprah was a troll and she just goes around.
She's bored with it being a billionaire.
So she goes around just trying to get people to talk shit in trapping people
like pitch.
I'm Oprah smack.
That's her new show,
bitch.
I'm Oprah,
which is at a certain point in time,
if she really wants to go out gangster,
now's the time to really go for it.
Bitch,
I'm Oprah.
Should it be the name of her next show?
Right.
You should run it.
I would run that because I understand the black people.
I have written on about five black shows and I don't know why,
but my first writing job was on Cedric the entertainer presents Cedric St Louis
Black Guy who fucking sings and dances.
I get hired to write his monologues,
just me.
Wow.
Then I go on.
I wrote on a
kind of,
let me ask you that before you stop,
how did you do that?
Like what was the process?
Well,
Louis C K was on the show and I told them,
look,
I haven't
seen my one year old son and a year because I've been on the road so much.
I need a writing job.
So he sets up a meeting with Cedric and I came in and I pitched him a few ideas
for monologues and I said,
well,
why are black people,
I was the first ones kicked off reality shows if there's a vote,
if it's survivor,
you gotta be like Tyrone,
I know you were a green baret you saved us from that Barracuda.
You set up the tent during storm but you black man hit the pavement.
So I gave him like three ideas like that and he was like sold.
And then we would sit a,
the shows were taped on Friday nights.
On Monday.
I just hang out in his office with him for like an hour and we would just shoot
the shit,
you know,
not topical ideas,
just you know,
anything.
And we'd shoot the shit and a writer's assistant would sit there,
tap,
tap writing,
everything we said down.
And then I'd have a couple of days to kind of compile it,
tweak it,
punch it up,
show it to him,
and then he'd go,
yeah,
I like this,
I like that.
And that was it.
Friday,
getting makeup put on me.
While you've got to remember,
he would rehearse and choreograph an entire dance number.
He was incredible.
And so he would come out on stage,
do a dance number with the sensei sensation dancers finish,
hit his mark and do the monologue.
No teleprompter,
no cue cards.
All he had was me after Wednesday.
I would sit in is a makeup room while he was getting made up.
And I would be like a given like a one sheet of paper.
You know,
we're going to talk about the Amish and ut hit this,
beat this,
beat this beat.
You go out on this Joe.
Got It.
Okay.
Thanks Greg.
Thanks.
Fits dog.
Nail it every time.
Wow.
So that was,
that's,
that must've been a fun Gig to write in someone else's voice.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was.
And then what was great is I was surrounded by,
you know,
it was Louis C,
k and j Johnson and uh,
so all black writers except for me and Louie.
And so it was like on tape night.
It was fucking crazy.
We would,
uh,
every,
every guy's office was a different vibe.
You know what one guy had the fucking bong go.
It was just pot.
And the next one,
there were these girls called the,
the dangerous dimes,
cause dimes with black people as she's a 10.
And they were,
they were these girls and all of a sudden on tape night you'd see it looked like
prostitutes that just got off the bus,
walking through with fucking micro mini dresses and those thick black thighs,
stiletto heels and makeup was a door and walk went off.
I'll fuck.
Yeah,
yeah.
Tell me no,
I mean,
not with one.
I mean I used to,
no,
I mean like close the door like right into a sink,
right on your feet
on that show.
I was jerking off in the men's room one time and uh,
my is the first week of work
and the men's room had a urinal and a,
a and one,
a stall stall.
And I'm in there and I'm jerking off and I'm just climaxing and the door to the
stall opens and it's my boss show runner.
Did he know you were jerking?
I doubled over anyone.
Oh.
And he walked out and I waited like 15 minutes and I came back in the writers'
room,
just looked at my computer fucking and nothing said about it for like a week.
I'm like,
am I going to get fired?
And then we're,
we're taught every talking one day and somebody is talking about taking shit and
he goes,
Jesus,
I walked in on Fitzsimmons the other day.
He was,
he was rich.
He was like doubled a,
you know,
I locked the door next time and I was like,
thank you.
You thought I was taking a shit.
Oh,
that's so funny.
So,
so you were sitting down jerking off right on the toilet seat.
Wow.
Yep.
Well he thought you were just struggling.
He thought I was struggling.
[inaudible]
legal.
Are you shooting one onto the floor?
Where were you coming?
I would take toilet paper and I'd put it over the crown and I would just kind of
slowly,
that would look like you're about to wipe.
Like you walked in,
you're about to wipe.
Right.
Wow.
And that's a very anal move to cover it with a low,
the cover your load with toilet paper.
She catch it.
It never happened.
That's right.
You never see it and happened.
Shane be gone.
It's a good idea.
This would do at the end of a fleshlight should be all tissues to catch it.
Doesn't it seem like there should be a condom in a fleshlight that you can just
remove like a liner?
You'd lose the feeling that patented rubber is patent for a reason.
Yeah.
It's too mushy to be that thin.
If it was that,
then it probably won't.
You're no longer a spokesperson for the fleshlight.
Correct.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Um,
that was,
uh,
one of the things where more people told me not to do it.
Then almost anything I've ever done more people like you regret.
It
doesn't,
it's something you fuck.
Who Cares?
Like the idea that it's evil or CD or what are you pretending you don't like
something touching your penis?
We really pretending that.
Or are we pretending it's only noble if you do it with your hands?
Are you allowed to use lube?
Are you allowed to do?
No,
no,
no.
You can only jerk off out of necessity.
You have to dry ticket in the shower to just be upset with yourself the entire
time.
Let's just a hit over what's really quickly now.
People look forward to jerking off and that's why there's a a billion porn tapes
out there.
And that's why fleshlight sell like hotcakes.
You know what's crazy?
As you think about all the sexual positions you'll have with your partner,
you're always trying to be creative,
try something new.
It's exciting and most people jerk up.
Most people.
Hell,
how the fuck do I know?
[inaudible] I know that I,
I don't try anything.
Kick him out as a teenager,
you know,
I'd fuck everything.
You know,
my pillow.
I now it's just like same type of porn.
Usually the same spot.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
Do you like that you get into the Webcam stuff?
Have you tried that?
Never liked the web.
I remember one time I,
uh,
had a date with this chick.
It was just after high school and I kind of had a thing for her in high school.
We never did anything.
They were going to meet up and she was like DTF,
like completely down to fuck and I was working,
I was
doing construction and I was so horny thinking about it all day because it's
been a while since I got some that I jerked off twice at work.
Not once,
twice,
twice.
I jerked off once in a bathroom at one time I shot a load out of the door.
Who working,
where can the unfinished basement and it had like a basement door and I just
looked around but then that night when I hooked up with the girl I could barely
get it up.
I was tired from work cause I had a construction jobs.
Like at the end of the day you were beat and I was beating off all day so that
made me tired and I just like,
my desire was gone.
I had already come twice in a day like an idiot.
Like once is a good move.
I twice as ridiculous to do that.
I'm one time Charlie.
I was like,
I was working this club early on.
I was like the opening act to catch a rising star down at Princeton,
New Jersey.
Oh,
I remember that Gig.
Yeah.
Near the college near the college.
And you stayed in a hotel and it was a beautiful high at,
so it was a Gig that all the New York comics like you to take the train an hour
and 20 minutes down and you stay in a nice hotel,
good room.
Anyway,
so there was this one chicken and you know,
there's always the one girl that people know,
Oh yeah,
when you're there Jenny,
she'll take care of it,
you know,
she's the one that fucks.
So we'd go out to like a Red Robin restaurant after the show and she's flirting
with me.
And uh,
she's,
she was like a physical therapist with short blonde hair and it was really rock
hard body.
I'm taking my pants off right now.
Good rack,
good solid rack.
And uh,
so she says,
so we're talking,
I go,
well,
you want to go to my eye?
She goes,
I can't really go in the hotel because I worked there.
And she goes,
you know what,
just let me in the back door.
So I let her in the back door and she comes up to my room and uh,
she is,
what do you call down to fuck?
She is e t t.
F.
So she goes down and she blows me and I,
and I,
and I blast.
And then she,
she wants to make love with me too,
like,
and I,
for the only time in my life I couldn't give it up and she got pissed and yelled
at me and left.
She yelled at you not yelled,
but she was frustrated and disappointed in me and it came through.
We felt like,
were you sober at the time?
Yeah.
So it was just,
you just had nothing left.
I just can't,
I can't do that.
I never,
I've never been able to do that.
Huh.
It's funny that she got mad.
Yeah.
I would get mad too if I was a girl.
I get it.
Well that's why I would say likely with oral sex,
there's no upside for women.
Right.
For us,
does it help side?
Because if we go down on her,
she's ready to rock.
After that,
everyone's getting laid after you go down on her.
If she goes down on you,
you may just leave.
So I had to be a woman.
I know it is,
but think of having babies growing signed yet.
That's the benefit.
That's the,
that's the upside.
Yeah.
If you give a guy a blow job,
you can't get it up again,
but you can make people with your pussy.
Right.
Did you guys hear which take Virgin Airlines is doing comedy now on the actual
no plane
please.
They used to do that on the,
on the flights to London.
Right.
Please tell me that.
Yeah.
And you can let go on their Twitter page and to find out who's playing and
stuff,
but can you imagine that with your job?
Like I'm playing for the next week in the air.
You know what?
That would be hilarious.
Bring a friend and videotape it and just do fucking crazy shit.
Yeah,
that would be awesome.
Member of the time,
me and Joe got hired to do,
to just be funny at an aquarium in Boston for a corporation.
It was like their Christmas party and we got hired and we're like,
oh great,
we're going to do stand up at this Christmas party.
And then they tell us no,
no,
no.
Just just walk around and do funny stuff like no one knew we were comedians
cause it was like,
you know,
a couple of hundred people.
So everybody had know each other and like we're eating off people's plates and
making fun of their ties.
And we were just,
people fucking hated us.
It was,
it wasn't working.
Say for the record.
I did not eat up anybody's plate.
Greg did.
I did.
He was just being funny with a big smile on his face to the guys strawberry and
this guy wanted to kill.
Right.
And I was like,
Oh my God,
this guy's going to hit him.
Something's going to go out.
And the guy just goes,
you're a fucking asshole.
And it was like,
whoa.
Like this just got real.
So I just,
so I just went in the corner,
it started eating fucking hors d'oeuvres and then all of a sudden I hear on the
loudspeaker,
I hear Joe on that.
He found the microphone and he's like,
I've tension.
Uh,
uh,
any parent with a child with a blue sweater,
he's now floating in the shark tank.
Please report to security.
And people thought it was real.
It was fucking,
I don't,
did we get kicked out or just laughing like that happened?
I know I didn't get paid.
I didn't get paid.
I don't think I was like 200 bucks.
We should,
it should have never happened.
No one should have ever liked.
Got a bunch of 20 year old comedians and said,
go do whatever you want to do at this aquarium.
It was an ad agency trying to be creative,
trying something new.
You dummies.
I think the plane thing would be fine as long as you didn't have to be a part of
the show.
Like what if you're trying to get some work done?
And the guy's like,
where are you from sir?
I,
they're like,
oh no.
Like I'm sorry.
I have an hour for,
oh,
somebody said Nas whole doesn't want to play along.
Like,
oh,
he's got an hour,
I've got to work.
I have to write things I have to do.
I didn't know I was going to have to react to you.
It's almost like you should be in a soundproof booth and the people that want to
hear you put on their headphones,
but if you don't want to hear it,
you can't hear it.
Like,
or like a whack off booth.
You're a comedian.
Yeah,
and if you don't have the headphones,
he's just like,
ugh.
That's too complicated.
Where,
where do you think the comic was stand?
I guess.
What about cat first class?
People would probably pissed.
That'd be the most likely to say this is bullshit.
I want to see a fucking comedian.
I got to do my spreadsheet.
So maybe it would be like in the middle,
like when FirstClass separates to coach,
they'll stand right there and do their little app.
Meanwhile FirstClass if they want to do it right.
I don't know if this has been done.
I think playboy or Hooters,
Hooters had a plane at one point.
Who does that?
A plane.
Yeah.
Yep.
That was my dream to take it.
But like there was like one flight and it was like Oklahoma.
It's totally loved all the time.
Like people would fly to Oklahoma just to fly to Florida to error.
Well you know,
more transfer over to a Hooters.
Got To stop shop.
But imagine getting a lap dance and first class on a flight,
right eyes.
Oh,
that'd be amazing because I could,
I could have,
you know,
five hours of really high and strippers just walking around gently giving lap
dances.
Not No fucking van Halen blasting,
just just cool,
cool lap dances to sleep.
Really slow music,
nice and central.
Sit through growing the tits in your face and just gently knocking them back and
forth way sit there and go,
ah,
the lap dances.
A very strange creation.
It is.
Eddie Bravo has a fucking hilarious story about the birth of the lap dance about
he was working in a comedy club and he saw the lap dance become a feature and
that before that it was just,
the women would dance on stage and then it was like,
well we got a new thing,
you're going to be able to do lap dances.
And most of the girls were like,
fuck that.
I'm not sitting on anybody's fucking loud.
Big Line to cross.
Yeah.
But one girl did and the first day this one girl made just fucking ass piles of
money.
And so after that there was like one extra girl the next day and then two girls
and then four.
And before you know it,
they were all doing it.
Yeah.
But it took a while.
It's just they,
they had to just start bringing in money and they only grow.
I mean people would be like,
be like waiting in line to get lap dances from this one girl.
And this one girl was just sitting on everybody's Dick Bear Pussy.
Like they're allowed to do that.
They sent me your Dick Bear Pussy where everywhere.
No Shit.
Everywhere.
That doesn't serve alcohol.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Have you seen people when I was in Montreal and Montreal is pretty famous for
the Strip clubs [inaudible] and um,
I was there for six nights.
I didn't go to one and I just had no,
fuck.
I figured I might go,
who knows?
People go as a group,
right?
I Dunno.
I think,
I think that
you were over it.
I think I'm over it.
I don't know why.
I don't know if it's cause I have a daughter
or it just,
I don't know.
Massage parlors are so much cheaper.
It is.
If you think about the actual,
if you go to the right ones and get the actual result you're looking for,
how much does that cost?
Oh,
depends what you want.
What do you want going to jerk you off?
There's some where you gotta go.
Okay,
come on back.
They're gonna open up the curtain.
Brian's got a table set up back there.
You'd get a lot more guests on the podcast come back with a wig on.
There'd be like 10 guests in here every day.
It's handjobs places are much more common,
but blow job places are pretty easy.
And Florence sex places,
there's about 20 that I know of here in Los Angeles.
How much is it to go get a massage and a hand job,
a saw and a hand job?
You'll
be in and out with a hour massage for like 80 bucks.
Cheap.
It would be nice if it also came with a magic wand.
You presses the back of their head and they would forget everything that
happened.
Yeah.
They develop the ability to Zap someone and you lose the last 30 minutes of,
of memory just to complete full eraser.
Oh,
you don't want the,
you don't want them as Seuss.
Remembering who you are,
where you could sneak out that way.
You don't have to feel the shame like nothing ever happened.
Right.
To knows nothing ever happened.
They usually say,
I go to,
I go to massage places that are like 39 bucks,
45 bucks,
places usually do those places offer the happy ending.
Well,
like I've said before,
you can go to rub maps.com to find out exactly which places to go to.
Pub Map rub.
Like are you be right?
It could be a Dick and PAS,
but don't go to the rug map maps.
This is a confusing fucking website.
What does Brian Redman talking about?
Right.
But most places do that.
The big thing is,
is that when you usually go to these $40 places,
you're usually keeping your underwear on.
Your usually putting a towel over you.
You're,
you're not doing anything to make them think that you want anything different.
Right?
So what you do is,
the easiest thing is just to take off all your clothes.
That's the big thing.
Like just take it all off,
throw all your towels on the floor,
don't,
you know,
just let her put a towel on you if she wants to.
And then if she's,
she'll start rubbing and you know,
and then you just kind of like,
you know,
moving around,
looking,
wondering,
he's giving a seminar on how to get chirped off really seedy.
My start rubbing her,
you know,
does she say it'll cost you this much?
Uh,
usually it's just given like you just tip,
like you just look up.
If she's going to give you a hand job that's like 40 bucks.
Just it's kind of like a,
a law,
like you know,
40 bucks.
I gave her 10 blowjobs sats,
sexist 100.
What if you just gave her a 10?
When she say something?
Maybe some places.
Well,
she probably would if she's an older person.
Like a lot of the older ladies,
they've been around so long,
they're hands are the softest.
Okay.
Oh God,
he's doing material now.
I'm not,
I don't know.
It's true.
They had the softest hands on the road.
It's like a little kid's hand.
They'd been jerking guys off forever.
That's like climbing up a rope for a year of your life.
But opposite.
It's opposite.
Yeah,
because it's just skin and oily cock.
That's right.
There's an oil on our hand every day.
He's rubbing it back.
But it doesn't matter if your skin gets more brittle as you get old.
There's no way getting around it.
You can't do it.
Get around it with soaking it in oil.
They're going to have a leathery old soft omit,
greasy,
leathery softball,
mint jerk and you up.
It's like Tom cost soup.
You know,
that's why you should have them use their feet.
Why isn't this someone's breath like someone would?
Stinky breath is one of the worst turnoffs in the history of the world.
Without a doubt.
Someone's talking to you in that breath stinks you,
I mean,
even like for having a conversation with someone,
even nonsexual.
But if you're attracted to a girl and you start talking to one of her breasts
and he's like,
Oh
God,
what do you do?
What do you do?
Do you tell her?
Did you try to be polite?
That's funny you say that because I had a really good friend for a lot of years
and she was,
she was cute.
You know,
she was like a solid seven and a half to change shit.
Breath,
great personality.
Fucking single,
no dates and her breath stank.
Oh,
and I didn't know.
I think I erred in not just anonymously sending her a note or an email to never
told you.
You never told her.
I never said anything.
And you know,
a lot of times I think it's probably like tooth decay or something.
Yes.
Ginger Vitus I mean if it smells like an antique bookstore,
that's usually,
yeah,
it means that you have some kind of like ginger bitus.
It's a bit of a like a run hour,
like a rotting smell.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's really bad.
I mean,
you see people with like if you have,
um,
I had a root canal once I had an old filling,
I cracked my tooth and then they'd filled it in,
but then someone another under the filling,
it's sort to go bad so they could drill in and give me a root canal.
And as he went through the tooth,
it popped into the,
the Reese,
the abscess and it made this horrible smell.
It was so nasty,
man.
It like,
I could smell like rot.
I go,
Ooh,
I goes down like the rotten tooth that smells like that.
He goes,
yeah,
that's what they smell like when you opened them up.
[inaudible] nasty.
Yeah.
It was like that Shit's just living in your inside my tooth.
Like you had to drill through my tooth.
My,
I had cracked underneath.
Um,
I have some cracks on my teeth from lifting weights from grinding your teeth.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Like I went to the doctor once and the the dentist and he was like,
do you like grind your teeth at night when you sleep?
Like if you were in a car accident,
like your teeth are all cracked,
like,
and then I go,
no.
He goes,
do you lift weights?
And I go,
yeah.
He goes,
okay,
you got to get a mouthpiece or something.
Look what you're doing your teeth.
And he shows me like the microscopic view of my teeth are all cracked like all
over the top of them.
And so apparently one of the filters had gotten like a loose or something and
some,
some deposits or something or they got in through the bottom of the filter.
Like there had been an opening somehow or another just enough to get the party
started and that's all you need is some form of decay underneath the filling or
inside a gum line and then just rots right through.
You're this tooth right here got knocked out when I was about 15 years old and
they did a root canal and put this calf on
fucking 31 years later.
No problem.
Strong as it ever was.
And it's a bottom tooth so you don't really see it.
Um,
Mike,
um,
Mike Goldberg,
the guy do the UFC with,
he's got his front teeth.
They had to actually drill posts.
I think you got them knocked out playing hockey.
Yeah,
mine has a post.
Oh that's right.
Yeah.
But his was like,
he had a one that was clip on with a magnet for awhile when they were in the
middle of doing it.
Have you seen those really?
Yeah.
May Slides Klink who would clip on with a magnet and you're like,
what the hell?
Like you know,
like a piece of metal in his fucking jaw.
This screwed in there.
Like the for this
and it has to sit there for a while.
Right.
Is that what the deal is that has to grow into your bone and actually has the
menu with your,
your bone is titanium rob telling you they put a post on this?
I it has no wiggle whatsoever after all these years.
Did you make you some bad ass teeth?
That's right.
That's nice.
That's the saddest thing in the world when people have no fucking teeth.
Yeah,
and it's expensive too.
And then if you get a bad job done,
then fucking,
you get coffee stains on it or if you smoke and it's a different color.
I had a friend,
I had a friend who was a pool player.
His name was Mount Vernon Tommy,
who was like a,
one of the best pool players around white plains,
New York,
like would gamble,
like spend like all this money.
He's worked.
He worked as a dispatch guy for a tax cab company and we work insane hours,
like 20 hours a day,
16 days in a row and build up a pile of cash and then come in and play pool.
I'm trying to put together a bank rules so I can get some action.
He didn't have a tooth in his mouth and this poor guy used to,
he used to like occasionally.
Oh,
got me a few layman you own.
I go,
how do you eat?
How do you your steak?
And he goes,
well yeah,
kind of a problem.
I couldn't chew it up.
So what I'll do is I'll just put it in a blender,
blend it all up nice.
And then I'll just eat it like that.
No Shit.
He literally couldn't chew anything.
He had zero teeth.
He had no teeth.
What happened to his tea?
Just disease could be anything.
It could be fights.
I'm sure lost some in fights,
bad.
Uh,
dental hygiene.
You know,
there was a time where people just weren't brushing their fucking teeth all the
time.
Some people,
you know,
and this guy was,
part of that and he just had terrible teeth.
Hygiene,
lost all his teeth.
How often do you floss?
I'd never flossed.
He never flossed never floss.
I brought the shit out of my teeth,
but I don't floss.
I floss like once a week.
Then once a week,
if I have a steak dinner,
if I feel like I got,
I got like a couple of spaces between my Maulers and like every meat meal I got
a nice fucking chunk and I,
and I'll try to suck it out sometimes for 35 minutes,
you know,
just going after it,
sucking,
sucking.
And then when it comes out,
it's like so tender,
you know,
it's like been completely tenderized and your molars and that you shoot with
your front teeth and it's delicious.
I was watching this,
uh,
special,
or,
uh,
a television show on these bear hunters.
They were going hunting grizzly bears.
So very strange thing to watch because you're part of you is like,
man,
I don't know.
Like you're,
you're not going to eat that.
you're shooting this animal for its health.
Like this is fucking crazy.
And then the other part,
when you see the actual animal dead and you like,
you look at its jaw,
you open its mouth and you see these fucking massive teeth of this enormous
head.
And it just really puts into perspective how weird teeth.
All right.
You know,
we have these flats,
stupid,
shitty ones that crack real easy.
This motherfucker is something that can eat trees like these are,
these are giant swords like embedded in his brain.
You know,
these huge fucking slicing swords that are attached to his face with it.
Yada could crush a fucking anvil.
It's,
they're just incredibly powerful.
Meanwhile,
while I'm kind of on the bear side,
that's what's fucked up.
I'm watching this.
I'm like,
I don't see Matt.
Unless you have to manage a population.
Like you're having a problem with them.
Like killing people's animals are going after people.
Like you're going to a place where there's no people and you're fucking up these
barriers.
It's like a weird sort.
If you're eating it,
I get it.
If you want to eat like black mayor,
people eat black bear,
but I don't think people really eat grizzly bears.
I think they only shoot them for their pelts.
I think they probably tastes like shit.
We should find out,
oh,
it's like a miracle man of beast like that.
Or a lion to see them asshole.
It's just like,
it's in its nature expressing itself in the coolest fucking way,
but still terrifying.
Like I um,
did you,
uh,
there's a story about,
these,
uh,
Japanese soldiers that had an enter these mangrove swamps and uh,
I'm not sure where it happened.
I put it on my Twitter,
uh,
two days ago.
It's a terrifying fucking story.
1,000 soldiers,
one of the swamps and 20 got out what they were all eaten by crocodiles and the
there no that,
no,
there was no Rico's nothing to do,
but just keep going.
And so all around them they're hearing thrashing where a crocodile will grab a
guy and then you hear screams that eventually go under water where the CROC is
like flipping them in role in them and it's pitch black.
So it's pitch black and these guys are walking through crocodile infested
swamps.
Thousand thousand men went in,
20 got out long ago,
1940s.
Let me find it.
Yeah,
you're going to shit your pants.
It is a crazy fucking story.
It's why somebody should compile the 10 events in life that most resemble what
hell would be.
Yeah.
Here it is.
Um,
I should keep the guy prompts or send it to me.
I'm a dude named Van Dave van Dave sent it to me.
And so death in the swamps of Ram Murray is the article.
It's on my Twitter feed from 15 hours ago.
Um,
so it was in Burma,
rolling jungles of Burma.
So in World War Two,
these Japanese soldiers when into a southern Burma and between 900 and a
thousand imperial infantry,
they were treated approximately 10 miles through the mangrove swamps.
In an effort to sync up with a larger defensive force.
And this is a fucking,
I don't want to read you too much on this.
This is a fucking crazy story.
It says,
the scattered rifle shots in the pitch black swamp punctured by the screams of
wounded men,
then crushed in the jaws of huge reptiles and the blurred worrying around
blurred worrying sound of spinning crocodiles made for a cacophony of hell that
has rarely been duplicated on earth.
At dawn,
the vultures arrived to clean up with the crocodiles had left of about a
thousand Japanese soldiers that had entered the swamps of Ram.
Re only 20 were found alive.
What a great way of describing that.
The scattered rifle shots at um,
Gary Mortenson acid.
Good fucking rights is an excerpt from a book,
um,
to get you to nope.
No,
it's just a,
a historical account.
World War II history,
World War Two history blog.
It's a World War III blog.
World War i.com.
Forward Slash blog.
I love shit about World War II.
I love just Google death in the swamps of [inaudible]. [inaudible] is actually
by a Steve Terje.
Listen,
that's the gentleman who wrote it.
Steve [inaudible].
But in the bottom it says written by Gary Gary Mortenson.
And then,
okay,
that last thing that I said,
the scattered rifle shots,
that's even written by a different guy.
British naturalist Bruce.
Right.
I'm attached to a Royal Marine Division.
Made the following notes of what he witnessed.
Ooh,
that was a night where Mr. Count.
Oh my God.
That's amazing.
What a great imagine your life.
If you're one of the 20 that survived the survivor guilt that you would have the
terror.
Yeah.
Terror.
I mean the terror that your nervous system to be,
go to a heightened state of everything that was just described for probably an
hour.
Oh,
more than that man didn't,
didn't win.
Then they talk about 10.
How many miles did they said it was two miles?
I think 10,
10,
10 miles through the mangrove swamps.
So how fast do you walk to walk through mangroves?
Yeah,
three miles an hour.
If you're lucky,
that's like a three hours.
Do you even walked three miles an hour through swamps?
Proudly less.
Probably less.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck Dude,
I'm shitting my pants right now.
Just thinking about that.
Not to mention Burma.
Burmese pythons.
Oh yeah.
Did you hear about that python that got loose in Montreal?
Yeah.
Montreal.
Is that where it was somewhere somewhere you boys or something?
Yeah.
No,
it wasn't Montreal.
Somewhere in Canada went through,
uh,
in a ceiling and killed these boys got out of like this reptile shop,
19 foot fucking python.
And Jesus.
I mean that's,
they said it's big enough to swallow an antelope pole and you've got this thing
just laying around.
Think about how big that is.
Can swallow an antelope poll.
It's like,
oh my waist,
my waist and a snake.
Yeah.
What the fuck man,
that's incredible.
Yeah,
I see those,
those things you should have,
you should have to have like really special,
precautionary,
like fail safe sort of ways to keep something like that contained.
If you're going to keep something like that alive,
you might have to put up muzzle on
it unless they're feeding.
But even then,
well,
how do I know if that muscle's gonna to stick?
What if the thing figures out how to get the muzzle off right?
You know,
you gotta you gotta a donkey eating monster on your hands,
right.
Wandering around.
Yeah.
And it needs to eat.
They have a real problem with those fucking things in Florida.
They're offering all sorts of rewards.
They had a thing in the everglades.
Yeah,
they had a thing recently where they offered rewards on the people bringing them
back.
I'm like,
fucking nobody was catching.
Nobody's catching them.
No.
I read about that.
And they're like,
this is a real problem.
Well,
we know they're there
and knows our,
um,
what kind of snakes for that?
Oh,
those are pythons.
Are they pythons?
Yeah,
Florida is so fucked up.
They found Nile crocodiles in Florida now,
and there's only one way for them to get there.
Someone had to let him go.
So they don't think there's a breeding population of them yet.
But there's a shoot to kill order on Nile crocodiles.
Like if you see them,
you have to fucking kill them like right away because they're aggressive and
they get to be 28 fucking feet long.
Like you got to kill those things.
These are not like the American crocodiles that exists now.
American crocodiles are much smaller,
very aggressive,
much more aggressive than alligators,
but much smaller.
But these Nile crocodiles,
holy fuck,
they're Willdabeast eaters.
You know,
that.
They're really aggressive,
really
alligators.
I mean,
I've been around alligators a lot because we used to have a house down in
Florida and it had,
um,
it had a pond across the street that had alligators in it.
So we're very aware and we saw them a lot and uh,
I saw the way they moved and they check you out,
but they'd ultimately swim away or not move crocodiles.
They're going to come up and go after you.
Yeah.
They see you and they'll lock on you and come after you.
Right.
Fuck lizards,
man.
Fuck all those creepy reptiles.
They that the people that think they're cute.
I th I see monsters.
That's all I see.
I see.
Heartless monsters that don't give a fuck about you or anybody.
They don't.
Yeah.
And you can own that thing for 20 fucking years.
It's never going to give a shit.
It's a cold blooded.
Yeah.
But they're beautiful.
I see that.
Yeah.
They're fascinating.
I see that.
Absolutely fascinating.
Yeah.
All,
all the reptiles to me,
when I look at them,
even chicken,
you know,
I've chickens,
even chickens,
I see my chickens.
Oh,
I see something that existed millions of years ago.
Weird life form.
We just think it's normal because we,
you know,
get eggs from them and they go [inaudible] we all seen chickens.
We've all seen it seems normal.
That's not normal.
At all.
What the fuck is that thing?
Some weird bird that can barely fly,
can only like get like three or four feet above the ground and then it falls
down and it's all plump and weird with dinosaur feet.
Yeah.
They're,
they're monsters,
man.
And they just live from fear.
They just run from Shit,
peck,
peck at everything,
just clean up.
They just clean up everything
and we just see them as food on legs.
It's just pure food.
You eat almost the entire fucking thing.
Yeah.
It's the most efficient food source among animals.
Well,
what's efficient about chickens is that they make eggs and you eat the eggs
every morning.
Do you do that every day?
They're,
they're delicious because we feed him vegetables too.
Like leftover vegetables.
We feed them to the chickens too.
They're there,
but they're omnivores.
They worms.
We feed them warm sometimes.
Right.
But the what people,
what I didn't know,
um,
I laugh at this because I've talked about this in the podcast.
People said,
what a fucking idiot I am.
But I didn't know this,
but I really didn't know until like,
oh,
I don't know,
a little more than a year ago maybe that a chicken doesn't make a baby with
those eggs that I thought,
I didn't know they made an egg every day.
No matter what.
I thought the only way to eggs,
if they fuck,
they make an egg every day and there's no rooster.
So none of these eggs are fertilized.
So they're just food.
Yeah.
So they're just food machines.
They make protein and it doesn't hurt them at all.
Like nobody gets hurt.
It's a natural process.
They do it every day and it's like,
it's one of the,
the best ways to acquire.
Like you can think it's like completely Karma free.
Like these no one's getting hurt.
Right.
This,
these eggs are just a natural process.
They don't stack them and fucking cages.
It's disgusting when you see these themes.
Corporate.
Yeah,
chicken farms.
But you,
you know,
you can do it in your yard is what I'm saying.
Right.
And it'll give you food every day.
I ran into a friend of mine when I was there.
I,
the dude,
well I shouldn't say friend,
that dude that I know from a Jujitsu and uh,
we were talking about like,
you know,
he's got,
he's got a rooster and uh,
they have eggs too and,
but they're a actually no,
no,
no.
They,
they have ag,
she has a rooster and he has two chickens.
Right.
But his chickens,
he's got a whole ecosystem gone.
His chickens can make chickens.
Like he's got the full setup up.
So like if with his eggs,
if the rooster fucks the hands,
those eggs can become checks.
So that gets real weird,
you know?
And that's like wow.
Like portion.
We got it.
You got,
well there's Balut you know,
that's the,
the Philippines eat,
the Filipinos eat,
it's like a duck embryo and you boil a duck embryo.
We served it on fear factor.
They love it.
They said they cook it in the egg.
Yes.
And then they open it.
Neat.
Yes.
Ambria yeah.
It was funny when we served it to people on fear factor in,
you know,
I know a lot of Filipino dudes from pool,
you know a lot of like high end pool players,
like some of the best in the world are Filipino and they love Balut.
They're like,
oh,
give it to me man.
I'll eat that shit.
Like they'd love Balut like volutes at Tri city.
No,
I don't need to you to be my friend Ross Broccoli is this comedian.
Great Name.
Yeah,
he's this really look this up.
If you can drive the getaway carrot top and make a salad shop,
is there another vegetable guy?
Uh
hmm.
Well they call me.
They accidentally a at the Faneuil hall comedy connection.
A black woman called the club and she say,
who on the show tonight?
She was from,
she was from the 18 hundreds and a and they said,
well it's Anthony Clark,
Jackie Flynn and Greg Fitzsimmons and a lady goes,
is Great Fruit Simmons,
the headliner.
That's a great name.
Call me.
Yeah.
Grapefruits.
And is to this day all the comics in Boston coming grapefruit,
Grapefruit Simmons.
I should have changed my name.
Right.
That's a great name.
Like,
like emo Phillips.
I know that's not his real name.
It doesn't offend me.
Try [inaudible] on his real name.
Either shaped fruit Simmons.
Right,
but look up Ross,
Broccoli and a and chicken truck.
Maybe you could go out from here on out as grape Simmons,
grapefruit Simmons,
the artist formerly known as Greg Fitzsimmons.
I need something for people to talk about it.
That's,
that's the kind of shit.
That's brilliant marketing.
If you're into that kind of thing,
just change your name every 15 years and have people,
you know,
I have to get the Twitter account,
change everything.
Grapefruit Simmons.
Well that's one of the ways that Madonna sort of stayed relevant all these years
is constantly changing.
She changed what she looked
like.
She changed her hairstyle.
She changed her singing style,
but always in intervals that allowed the public to,
you know,
adjust.
Yeah.
David Bowie did the same thing.
Yeah,
you're right.
Yeah.
David Bowie did a lot of that.
He did some weird shit,
man.
You know,
one time on the podcast we played dancing in the street.
Him and Mick Jagger,
we forgot like how insane that video is.
It's might be the weirdest like rock and roll video of all time because it's
Mick Jagger and David Bowie and they are dancing together.
And one of the most peculiar ways I've ever seen two men dance together.
Like even rock stars that are like singing songs together and they'll like lean
in together and use one mic,
you know,
so they're like go on face to face and sing in each other's eyes.
That's not as gay as Mick Jagger and David Bowie dancing and looking at each
other and like wiggling back and forth and like hopping up on like light footed
on one foot to one foot in like this weird display
for ability and a light light.
Footedness it's a very strange way of see,
just play the video of them dancing.
It's one of the weirdest place.
Pop and Bowie and Jagger.
I mean that whole gay thing.
I was probably what in like the early eighties late,
no,
earlier set up seventies I think.
I think there's a lot of guys that experimented.
Yeah,
they just,
it was really accepted.
Yeah.
I think those artists too,
like there was a lot of artists that wanted to open themselves up.
They wanted to find out,
you know,
like what are the boundaries?
Like what's holding me back creatively.
Yeah.
You know,
everyone's partying and everyone,
it's like almost like a,
an uh,
showing an openmindedness by trying to have sex.
Like there's a,
there's Jagger.
Oh,
in those eighties close.
Yeah.
It was weird with the cuffs.
That jacket with the cuffs pulled up the forearm Haslacker play some more of
that.
That's wild.
There's
w there was a weirdness to it the way they were dancing around.
Yeah.
Look at them.
I mean,
look at David Bowie's get this weird jacket on.
Like he's a lab assistant and Mick Jagger's got like high waisted pants,
a mullet and they're staring at each other's eyes
singing and there.
Oh,
he's grabbing his holy.
Yeah.
It's incredibly gay.
Whoa.
Now there,
but to but sing it.
Every guy,
grab a girl everywhere around the world.
I mean,
and nothing wrong with that,
but it's really what my point is,
is that it's very unusual behavior.
Not even done that it's gay because if it was gay,
like openly gay,
it would almost be less weird if there was like two guys and they had their
hands on each other's hips and they were singing and kissing each other.
I go,
oh,
I see.
That's how gay guys are.
They're gay.
They're attracted to each other,
so they're,
they're making out.
That's what gay guys making out.
That's normal.
That's not normal.
What is that thing?
That weird mating dance.
They're doing it right.
We think it's like date.
They both got to the point where they had fucked so many models and done so
many,
three ways that the sexual energy is just pouring out and they're just there.
Like you said,
it's like a mating dead.
There's strutting it out.
It's not really about fucking each other.
It's about both of them celebrating their raw sexuality.
Well,
it's,
it's weird as what it is.
It's weird sort of movement doesn't even seem sexual because it doesn't
represent any,
like when you see a woman dancing and a woman who's real sexy,
one of the things that you're seeing is when a woman's dancing,
you're seeing how she would fuck.
Yeah.
Like you're seeing a sensual sort of an appeal when a woman is like gyrating.
It's very attractive because what you're seeing,
you're thinking of movement,
you're thinking of making love and you're thinking of like bodies touching and
how good it would feel if she moved like that while she was touching you and how
what a turn on it would be just a blow away turnout.
That sexy.
Right.
But this is weird.
This is not sexual.
Like it's not gay.
I mean I'm calling it gay because it's just odd.
It's more queer than gay,
but it's not gay.
Cause if it was gay,
they'd be looked Rustin and grabbing Cox and looking at each other and holding
each other to pulling clothes.
But it's just weird.
It's like,
it's almost like boy George,
who we knew was gay.
So that added a sexuality to it because in people's minds,
gay and you just thinking about sex and yet he played it like a child
entertainer.
He dressed like a clown and there was nothing he did that was sexual in any way.
But he danced like that really fucking sensual.
Well Boy George was actually a good dancer.
Fuck yeah,
great movie.
It was a great singer.
That song.
Do you really want to hurt me?
That was a brilliant song.
Well I remember when that song came out,
how many dudes I knew who were angry watching that video.
They got angry.
Like you see this fucking guy,
she's Christ.
They would get mad cause boy George was in this like Puffy,
nondescript sort of like non body outlining sort of outfit,
this little puffy outfit and he's like gyrating and moving in slowly and
singing.
Amanda has makeup on a lot of makeup on and he's singing,
do you really want to hurt me?
Do you really want to make me cry?
I mean it's like wow,
it's heavy.
It's heavy.
Yeah.
And defining,
you know,
wake me up before you go.
Go.
I was just going to bring that up.
I remember I was working at Papa Ginos when the song became popular.
I was working at Papa Ginos in Newton,
Massachusetts and I was uh,
I was a cook there.
I was making like Spaghetti and whatever the fuck they sold.
And there was a girl who worked there who was in love with this guy and she was
describing this song,
wake me up before you go go.
And she was like,
he's so beautiful.
Like I can't even look at him.
He's so beautiful and like the song is a basing and so I went home that night
and I saw it on television and I was like,
that might be the gays human than ever walked the face of the planet and this
girl can't even see it.
Right.
She couldn't sit.
I think the damage girls are attracted to clearly gay guys like that because
they're non threatening their friends.
Yeah.
I think that,
you know,
w something that's that gay,
you think of Liberace and how many like frustrated Midwestern women would go see
him in Vegas and actually feel something while he's the bridge between
what a woman really would like a man to be.
What a man really is.
Yeah.
You know Richard,
Bill Cosby said something really funny once.
He said,
women don't want to hear what a man thinks.
Women want to hear what a woman thinks,
but in a deeper voice.
Okay,
brilliant.
Is Bill Cosby?
That is such a brilliant line.
That's good.
That is a,
that was a goddamn brilliant Laura.
Right?
But every now and then you have a bridge and the bridge is like a,
like a George Michael Sort of a guy's beautiful man,
you know?
But he's dancing around and he's,
you know,
he's got perfect hair and earrings to hoop earrings and a shirt that says choose
life
India.
Yeah,
that's what could rent.
Whose hand and an earring.
Yeah,
you left me sleeping in my bed.
She in the bed with you instead of wake me up.
Well,
you remember a certain comedian that we know who was gay who I don't think is
out of the closet and he used to sing.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
wake me.
You'll,
you give them away.
I don't give a shit.
Oh dare you wake me up before you go.
Go.
Cause I'm nothing but a fucking homo.
And this guy used to sing that clot and this is the guy who later on blasted
other comics who did homophobic stuff.
Well,
he was a little tortured.
Very tortured.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
there's another perfect example of someone who just came out of the closet.
Nobody would give a fuck.
People don't want this line of work.
You.
Yeah,
you're a comedian,
man.
That's why you think about that guy,
Jason Collins,
the basketball player who came out.
People say,
that's really brave and you've got to stop and go.
Why is it so bright like a comedian come out and act or
can come out?
Um,
you know,
in any facet of life,
you're an accountant and somebody came out,
people would adjust and deal with it.
But it's brave for a basketball player because athletes tend to be jocks,
ignorant,
hateful guys that don't like Gig.
They say fags a lot.
You know Kobe Bryant said that thing.
I think it's,
it's a bigger deal to come out in that environment than it is in other,
no doubt.
It's much as a very courageous.
And there's also the locker room element,
right?
There's the element of the fact that these guys get together in the locker room
and they fucking,
they're naked together.
Right?
Okay.
They're showering.
Would you,
I mean it's not the same thing,
but how much different with the dynamic of a locker room change.
If a woman came in and she was attractive and she was showering and she was
showering with men naked,
which completely changed the dynamic of the locker room,
right?
Well a gay guy who is in a locker and seeing all these yummy dicks and seeing
all these dudes soaping up their cocks like that for,
for,
for him,
like him being there would really change the dynamic of the locker room if he
wasn't professional.
And of course he would be professional and understand.
But most men would be professional too if they were hanging around a woman.
They want to fuck and I'm not,
I'm not playing.
So the theory is that
he's going to jerk off thinking about my dick.
Oh,
the fear is that he's going to fuck you while you're taking a shower.
That's the real fear.
No one know that.
It's real nice.
It's going to happen.
Press outside.
It's $1 billion arena.
They've got their own stalls.
Somehow he's going to to see your ass in your ass up like prison.
He's going to fucking hold you.
It's so amazing that that's the fear because my whole thing is if he jerks off
thinking about,
you'll never know
unless he tells you and then he makes it super uncomfortable.
It's just you and him and you go back because you forgot your sneakers and
you're like,
hey man,
I'll tell you a draft off to you last night.
It was fucking amazing.
Have a good game.
We were together,
we were shaving.
Should we have our bodies and what?
Hey Man,
I want you showering behind me anymore.
Fucking creep.
I mean that's,
well they say,
I don't want him,
he's going to be looking at my deck.
Here's a news flash.
If you're in a shower,
the bunch of other guys,
they're all like [inaudible] like I look at the decks,
but this is a different,
it's a different thing because it's not yummy and delicious to you.
You look at a dick and I'm like,
well there's something.
I don't want to have anything to do weird.
I just look at it cause it's weird.
You never see them.
I don't need to see your Dick.
You don't need to do anything with it.
You thanks.
Take care guys.
Yeah,
I saw you dick.
But no big deal.
Like in Jujitsu,
the
locker room and in the locker room,
everybody takes her clothes off and showers.
It's just normal.
But is it after the run and shower?
They're staunch.
There's the stall,
but there's only one.
So we all wait in line for it and we hop out.
You see someone's Dick,
they grab a towel there,
wrap it up,
whatever.
Nobody gives a shit.
You take your clothes off and put dry ones on.
You got to see your Dick,
it's just a normal part of everyday life.
But if you were there and it was by,
you know,
um,
what's the word?
Coed and uh,
there was in there,
it was changing as well and they were hot women and they came out naked.
Like that would be a weird dynamic if you're sexually attracted to them.
And I'm not saying that gay people would take advantage of you or they'd be
weird you.
But what I do believe about gay men,
unequivocably without a doubt equivocable is that their men and men can be great
or they can be creepy as fuck.
Both
since we're on the table.
Thank he knows he's so under the microscope as the gay guy in the shower,
then he would be completely control.
What is this bill with Tami Sagher getting some guys grabbing his dick.
Patrick Melton.
What is it is a sketch they did?
Yeah.
It's called feeding the rabbit and it's,
what's it about?
How long has it got loud?
It's a two minutes.
Play it.
Okay.
It's got,
what's that?
Uh,
yeah.
Let me turn it over real quick.
That's my play music on.
It's still rebirthing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Here's one mere cat nearby who doesn't have the luxury of group protection.
Tosca is very much on her own was two guys sitting on a couch watching a nature
show.
The toast pops up,
but it's likely she'll never be allowed to join her family again.
For the folks listening,
rabbit or solitude is fine.
Feeding the rabbit,
he says time to feed the rabbits and alive so he pops the stars,
the toes back in and they both get up.
First she tells time to take off is just to find an unrelated roving mail for a
mate.
Let's do this
perhaps for luck.
Isabel the change.
Carlos a roving mail from them.
I'm looking at each other in the eyes a lot of times how to tell to the whiskers
and Risa time looks like he's about the Pew.
Always in this guy's mind.
It's guys like making,
who's the other dude?
Patrick Melton.
Nobody likes.
He's making these horrible faces.
This looks like an opportunity like he's or gas.
Yeah,
nodding his head.
Medicine,
right.
Maniacal.
Icontact.
Deference to shame.
Understanding.
Regret.
It's early morning and the whispers of Tom's causes shaking his head no,
he doesn't like it a little ground.
God,
how long has this been
confusion?
Yeah,
this is really a visual bit.
We're not doing this thing.
Any justice.
Put the descriptions there.
There's the promise of a good,
and so he's making this crazy and they're both grabbing their decks,
the grabbing each other's Dicks,
and they're smushing them.
Oh,
there with the grab and the dicks with the underwear outside of the pants for
the toast.
Three pops and then with the toast pops up,
they'd done.
That's when they end it.
It isn't just beautiful.
It means that rain is formed and then sitting down and not going to talk about
it.
They don't get the toast.
Who the fuck of that?
That is an unbelievably weird sketch.
That's like,
you know how that's get started?
I want to grab this guy's Dick.
I'm going to write a sketch.
That's like,
they went for it.
Oh Man.
They took a deep and they didn't just take a deep,
they'll like they,
they hung in there for a long time.
You know,
it's weirder than grabbing the deck.
Is the eye contact from four inches away the whole time?
Yeah.
I guess though,
if you were gay,
that'd be hot,
right?
Yeah.
Gig.
I would watch it and he goes,
what's so funny,
right?
It was hot as fuck.
Yeah.
These two bears jerking each other off when the toast pops up.
I love it.
Bears.
I know bears.
That's my,
my second favorite.
Like Sexual Thompson,
Agora video.
My other ones,
the one rug with him and Bert Kreischer where they're shaving each other with no
shirts on.
Yeah.
You know,
I met,
I met Bert Kreischer for the first time in Montreal.
Oh,
I don't really know.
We were both looking at each other like,
how do we never fucking meat?
He's a great guy.
Yeah,
he's fun,
man.
It's fun,
Dude.
He's a different kind of the guy,
you know,
he's like a great party starter,
host type guy.
You know,
he's a different kind of guy.
He's got his own little thing going on.
Bert Kreischer,
should I have him on my podcast bird?
If you're out there a email me dog radio@gmail.com is awesome.
He's awesome.
He's got some diarrhea stories too.
Yeah.
Did you see the video of him and Ralphie may on stage or something?
Sad.
It made me sad.
They both have their shirt off and they're singing songs.
It's like,
okay boy.
Okay,
you guys need the hug.
Hold on here.
I just talked to Ralph.
I made the other day still not smoking the weed or anything like that.
He's wow.
He's not smoking.
We don't think so.
I'm sure he knows back Brian Post saying welcome back pitch welcome bags.
Oh that's right.
I had him on the podcast
and he was,
we caught him right when he was done.
He was a,
it was no,
uh,
he wasn't,
wasn't smoking any weed.
He's taken a big break.
It was trying to get his shit together.
I think though he was one of those dudes that much like your friend Mc Chris,
he just,
you know,
run over when went off the pot deep end kind of re,
catch your breath,
refocus,
shake it off.
Right.
Live a sober life for awhile and then slowly get back in with a more defined
sense of parameters.
Yeah.
Especially when you have a young kid.
I think he's really into his kid and I think it was probably affecting that on
some level.
Even if it wasn't,
you feel like it is
well,
especially if you're using it as an escape,
which sometimes guys do,
especially under stressful situations where it's like maybe have a kid or
worrying about your career.
There's people that will use it to,
instead of like dealing with their situation,
they'll sort of hide behind the pot.
Like they'll start smoking pot all the time and avoid dealing with like things
that they need to deal with.
That is a possibility too.
They can use pot actively or passively.
Yeah,
you could fuck up with anything,
man.
That's what I think.
I think it's Great Fruit Simmons
to cover over your next,
sandy gave me great.
Whoever made that.
Who
made that give,
give them some prompts.
Falling art or maybe falling ardor tell that story before and yeah,
I've met a couple of fans,
sent me artwork.
Oh that's slowly.
I got one up on the wall in my office.
That's the one that's on the wall in my office.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
that's so funny.
That's a good one to write your face.
That's got sort of a,
that's really similar.
Rawling at a fair.
That is really funny.
And so yeah,
I need,
I need a new brand.
That's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to change the grapefruit sevens.
How often do you do in your podcast?
You put her down every week.
Twice a week.
For four years now.
Wow.
How many episodes do you have?
400 or so,
but the back ones you have to get the premium membership for I,
I give,
I think the first 20 are free,
the most recent.
And then the back ones are premium membership.
And you have your show on Sirius errors at what time?
At seven o'clock on the west coast.
On Howard 101 on Monday nights.
And that's been going on for a long plus.
Six years.
Six years?
Yeah.
First sounded like five years ago.
You were like my first or second guessed.
Really?
Yeah.
Fucking great.
Oh Wow.
That's cool.
Yeah,
and it was a,
it was back when we hadn't hung out much.
We had,
you know,
we just hadn't been in each other's radar for awhile and it was like this
connection,
it was like fuck man,
that was like a electric,
it was so good.
Just you know,
focus,
talk in for an hour.
Yeah.
Thank God for podcasts and radio shows and shit where people can just sit down
and shoot the shit.
Like I was saying to someone on Twitter the other day,
someone who was saying they liked the podcast,
I was saying,
I love doing it too because one of the benefits for me is besides knowing that
people are enjoying is that I get to have these conversations,
right?
Like how often would we have the time to sit down for three hours and just shoot
the shit,
no cell phone calls and checking.
Nobody here in this room has checked the fucking text.
Nope.
Since we started.
No,
nothing.
You know,
and I think that makes for,
it makes for a good break.
And it also makes for like a deep intense conversation that maybe you wouldn't
have the time to do
otherwise.
Yeah.
I mean how many of your opinions like my opinions to me are,
that's who I am and the only way you're going to get ones that are legitimate
are to go deeply into it with somebody.
A couple of people that you respect.
Yeah,
and just and challenge each other.
Fuck around.
See what's up Greg Fitz show on Twitter.
Follow him.
You Dirty Fox.
Those three hours,
dude,
that was fast as shit.
It's three 23 are ready.
Don't forget Phoenix coming out there on the 15th to the 17th stand on live and
I best clubs in the country.
And when is your specialty
on August 18th on comedy central at midnight.
It is life on stage.
My one I respect.
Can't wait to sit.
I know it's going to be hilarious.
I saw that that material in Seattle and San Francisco is fucking hilarious man.
Funny Shit.
I appreciate him.
Our sponsor for today,
legal zoom.com go there.
Use a code name.
Rogan,
save yourself some cash and legal zoom is not a law firm.
You Fox,
they provide help service at your specific direction.
Halacha boy,
also on [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t use the code name,
Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
I've got some other shit going on this week,
folks.
I think we'll be back Friday,
late afternoon.
Um,
I will,
uh,
let you know soon and all those podcasts that you see on the TV show,
people have been asking me,
those are real podcasts.
They look like people would go to fig hurt my soul.
They're actually real podcast.
That's the only way we were willing to do it.
Duncan and I did real podcasts and they will be released as podcast eventually.
Uh,
but until the show stops,
Aaron,
it'll all just be just out recorded.
We got it though.
Don't worry.
All right,
we'll see you guys soon.
Thanks for all the love.
Big Kiss,
big hug,
big love.
So yeah.
[inaudible].